I'll tell you right now, if I was Tom, I would be clapping. I'd
be like, "Yes, yeah, let's go." Like, how could you not if you're
in that situation, right? So, I'm just trying to ruin your career
with like heinous lies and like that, right? I get it sounds
like Destiny, but Destiny's a loser. >> Thank you for the
following. >> I feel bad for Chud now. He's taking I don't
feel bad for Chud. Chud went live. This thing came out at like
what was like between 6:00 and 10:00 the night before and he
was up by 8:00 a.m. saying the great sweep is on and sicked his
entire [__] audience on me. I don't feel bad for
Chud, not one bit. >> The whole conversation we we were
at initially, you said, "Why can't we all get along and make
content? We can't." I said, "We can't make content cuz Nick's
a [__] problem." And now you're just It's like you're
just saying, "Yeah, Nick's [__] problem. He doesn't
want content with anyone." [music]
This is leading into the next story we got here. Give me a second.
[music] So,
on Twitter is basically saying that, you know, Sacramento posts
this text. All
And this text says, "I forgot to mention Turkey Tom's ex attempted
to dox an offline person I attended VidCon with in 2025. This
was done because she must have known something and she wanted
us to suffer for simply knowing Tom. This worthless gets no sympathy
from me." Where where's the doxing? What is the doxing element
here? Can anybody tell me where the doxing element is?
Cuz I I don't see it. Not to sweep. Oh, don't worry about it,
Auggie. Actually, Auggie, if you want to talk about any of this,
we we could totally talk about it. No, by all means, give me
the other side of the story because right now this looks very
goofy to me,
right? And I would say possibly fishing is bad. Yeah. Or requesting
docs is very bad, right? I don't like this. I don't like this,
Auggie. I'll be real with you. I'm not a fan. I'm not a fan.
I don't I don't think you dox people even in this case. You know
what I'm saying? Not a fan. I The Brandon Buckingham doxing thing
is pretty bad. Okay. This this dying is he really is he really
dying and he's like just throwing out a last minute dox. That's
up. He's got nothing left. Dude, it's it's crazy. Hold on. According
to her, we all deserve to get nuked and she was actively looking
for information on her. I assume Nicholas's girlfriend. I find
it absolutely hilarious that she was the only one to end up getting
blasted. And nobody can convince me why that isn't funny.
As a Kiwi farmer, you cannot cry about doxing. It's impossible.
Or are you saying she can't cry about it? Yeah, but that's different
from what I expect of other people, right?
Yeah, that's different from what I expect of other people.
I don't think you could just say, "Well, it's fair game to go
on Kiwi Farms and Dox people." I think this also got some sinister
implications as well for anybody who might have another allegation
against Dom
that you I you got to admit the optics are not good. Okay, the
optics are not good of, "Yeah, this person said this, they came
out with an allegation."
And while I think she's been categorically disproven to just
like instantly the day Tom drops his response, post her essentially
her full docks. That's wild, dude. That's
I'm not I'm not saying she didn't deserve to be like mocked out
of the room for everything she's posted.
I just don't know. I don't know if I'm at doxing yet, that's
all.
Uh she's been trying to ruin his life. I don't know if it's justified,
but I just don't care. Yeah. Well, unfortunately for us, we had
to deal with, you know, certain person using that exact logic
to justify doxing, you know, people I know, people I'm friends
with,
right? Oh, well, they're trying to ruin my life, so I don't care
if they're I I don't care. I'm just doxing them now. It's like
trying to figure that out, right?
Um, she was definitely going to Well, hold on. If she was definitely
going to Why doesn't she just dox the anonymous VidCon girl?
If she was just going to
That That's my question, right? If you were just going to dox
the anonymous VidCon girl, in my opinion, why would you Sorry.
If you were trying to dox the the Doryo girlfriend cuz she was
allies with that girl. Okay. Wait, do you want to call in, Auggie?
Would it be easier to do this call over voice? I don't think
I'm in my channel. Would you want to call in? We don't have to
do this through >> Yo yo, what's going on, man? Um, it
just seems like she obviously wanted to post that information
because she was mad because she was claiming that, and this could
be true, by the way. I don't know if it's true or not, but she
was claiming that Turkey Tom cheated on her at VidCon, right?
And this VidCon girl knew about the whole situation and she was
in communication with the VidCon girl uh because Dioro's girlfriend
had told her about all this type of stuff, right? Like Tom had
a girl back home or something like that, right? And so she was
mad and she wanted to get that information. Everybody in the
Kiwi Farms thread was obviously and I'm sure you know how Kiwi
Farms works, right? Obviously, they were going for >> release
anything. Yes. Yes. Of course. And so she was going to completely
with >> dude. It's like null, you know, asking both of
the girls when he has them on a call. He's not asking for like
contemporaneous texts that prove anything. He's like, "How big
is Tom?" >> He wants dirt. He want Everyone on that side
wants dirt. They don't actually give a about like for like the
allegation or anything like that. They just want funny material
to make memes of basically, right? >> Yeah. Yep.
>> Yeah. Sure. >> I just I I So I agree with you
that that's what they want. And I agree with you. She's definitely
gotten into a pattern or both of these girls have, I think, of
trying to get the approval of the thread, which is never going
to go well for anybody. Gay. Don't try to get their approval.
They don't like you. The second [laughter] you stop being useful,
they will totally turn on you. >> Yes. They're animals.
I mean,
sure, there are anonymous people on the internet. They're right
there some accountants on here, right? >> I don't blame
them. If I was like anonymous on the internet, I would be an
animal, too, cuz I wouldn't give a, right? But I'm just saying
like that's how they are. >> Like I'm guessing some of
them are like totally normal people outside of this. This is
like their little, you know, their catharsis.
>> It's just fun. It's sport.
>> Yeah. But I again I haven't seen an indication that
at least yet >> that she would post this.
>> Why would anything and everything else? Like what do
you mean? >> Humiliating Tom.
>> Did she post, you know, location information on somebody
else? I think >> she was
understand the difference, >> Well, she was obviously going
after me and Nick, too. I mean, she for one thing, I'll tell
you this, right? She lied and said that I lied because on my
stream when I covered the Tom allegations, she said that I lied
by saying I didn't know her even though Tom told me that he was
dating her. Okay, Tom told me he was dating some girl from Tinder.
I didn't know who she was. I didn't know what her name was. I
didn't know her face, what she looked like, literally anything
about her. All I knew was at some point Tama told me, "Oh, by
the way, I'm dating some girl that I met from Tinder." Right?
So on my stream when I said I didn't know her, she tried to say
that I was lying and saying that oh Aie knew who I was because
Tom uh told me about her or Tom Tom told him about me or whatever,
right? It's like that's not true at all. You know what I mean
by that, right? So she was gunning for Nick. She was gunning
for me and she was looking for anything she could post about
us later on after she had run out of funny juicy things to say
about Tom. The idea that she would not have posted Dioro's girlfriend's
information when obviously she's fine posting everything else
about Tom and everything else about his friends and everything
else about, you know, literally anything she can just to make
his life miserable. I just find that hard to believe. >> Hold
on. Why are we totally fine with, you know, Tom? I I'll just
say Tom making videos on the embarrassing personal details of
all these people who get it gets leaked on Kiwi Farms, but not
fine with him like doxing people. It's because doxing is like
a totally different thing and most people understand that, right?
So I while I understand that she is posting stuff to get back
at people and she's really mad at Tom, I think I've not seen
anything to me that shows that she would go and just dock someone
yet.
I mean, she's posting on a forum that's literally his docs. Like
what do you mean?
>> Like that's literally what the whole forum is about,
right? like the the front page, you can't even show the forum
the front page of the forum because it's his full legal name
and if you go to the first post or whatever, right? I'm sure
it has his address and everything about it on there, right? How
could you moralize about that? >> Could be. How could I
moralize if she's posting on QB Farms about her? I don't think
so. I think she's going after Tom. I just I'm saying she hasn't
doed when you post on indication she's going to dox somebody.
>> I feel like when you post on QB Farms, you just forfeit
the right to even complain about doxing at all because it's like
that is the website where But they don't even see that as like
an act of aggression.
>> Just to be clear, I'm not arguing that you, you know,
if she complained about this when she's participating in a forum
that is doxing Tom and probably doxing some of his friends, I
would guess. I'm not saying she could complain about it. I'm
saying I don't like I don't want people around me to join this
culture because I want the ability to say I don't hang out with
people who are just going to dox random dudes. Like I don't want
that because I don't want that to happen to me, right? I think
it's bad. >> That's fair. That's fair. I'm saying it's
bad. >> I'm right. >> That's completely fair. That's
completely fair. Um
I think there is some amount of context as to like certain things
like when people are doxed or whatever, right? Like Brandon doing
doxing her is not just some random attack or whatever, right?
Obviously, there's a reason why he's motivated to do that. And
you can say whether it's right or it's wrong or something like
that, right? But I think we can look at that situation and just
see it as like different than just like a random attack happening
or something like that, right? >> Absolutely. But like
you understand that's just the exact logic Destiny used to dox
people, right?
>> Uh do doxing who? >> Like it's not it's like not
uh trying to dox me, trying to dox a bunch of other people. I
don't even want to say other names, but like he's basically like
these people tried to talk about my [__] They tried
to like go after me for this and they should have their identities
exposed on the internet. Right. So, it's not like a random docs.
He like feels like he's justified in doing it. Right. >> Obviously,
if you're wrong by somebody, you might feel like you're justified
to do it. Doesn't make it okay to do >> in my opinion.
>> I understand that you guys are like you guys are like
friends and I do understand the idea that this person did try
to ruin Tom's reputation, did try to ruin his career, and you
feel like something should be done about it. I just would hesitate
to say that the appropriate response is doxing immediately because
of it basically is like you opening up a can of worms once you
support this sort of like >> Yeah. I mean, I get the I
get the hesitation as an outsider looking in on it or whatever,
right? I don't know. For me, like looking at it from my perspective,
when I saw Brandon do it, I'm not going to lie, this might be
horrible for me to admit. I was laughing. I thought it was like
just a crazy moment of just, [laughter] you know, like whoa,
like we're going off or whatever, right? And I was jumping up
and clapping. So, and I can't pretend like that wasn't my reaction.
I I to to pretend like I have some sort of moral uh problem with
it would be actually lying about how I really feel.
>> Yeah. It's not like uh that would be shock. I wouldn't
have been shocked by that with for Brandon, right? He did post
like that like sneak. >> I was shocked. I didn't expect
him to go that hard, but I was just like whoa. Like this is kind
of epic. Like
>> these stupid ruin people's lives. They want to throw
all this against [__] Tom and then cry when like
the same level of heat gets thrown back their way them. That's
how I was actually thinking in the moment
>> Yeah, I understand how you could feel that way in the
moment cuz it's your friend who got totally wronged. I understand
that emotional response, but then when you break it down, it's
like personal details. And I think he was able to reveal personal
details that allowed him to absolve himself and that, you know,
I I feel like he totally won here until he decided to do something
that I think exposes her identity when it wasn't exposed before.
And well,
if I if I'm not wrong, I believe >> Well, I believe no,
you could you could convince me of that. If people come out and
disavow Brandon, do you think there's any chance that Tom's coming
out and going, "Actually, Brandon, I can't hang out with you
anymore cuz you doxed this person."
>> I'm sure he wasn't offended by it, but I don't know
if like Tom's plan was to be like, "All right, Brandon, you do
the doxing. I'll do like the legitimate response." Like maybe
that I don't know. I I get how it looks, but like I just don't
know if that's exactly what
>> Well, I mean, it would be pretty hard to know unless
you were in the group chat. Like it would be pretty hard to know
if that was the exact thing, but it's how it looks. And when
there's no disavowel, it is him kind of saying, "Yeah, like that's
good." You know, I like that.
>> Oh, well, if I was Tom
right now, if I was Tom, I would be clapping. I'd be like, "Yes,
yeah, let's go." [laughter] Like, how could you not if you're
in that situation, right? Some just trying to ruin your career
with like heinous lies and [__] like that, right?
I get it sounds like Destiny, but Destiny's a loser. That's the
difference. So Destiny sucks and Tom is cool. That's the difference,
right? >> It's totally cringe and Tom's [laughter] >> Yeah.
Okay.
>> Sometimes it's okay and sometimes it isn't okay, right?
Like come on, >> dude. If if the excuse is just Destiny
sucks and we're cool, then you guys are just the same sort of
f as Destiny. Let's be real, >> I guess. >> Hey yo,
Twitch. Okay. Well, the Twitch
Sorry was here. I assumed you wouldn't be on Twitch with all
I assume it was >> Jesus Christ, bro. >> There's
no chat on your screen either. There's no chat on your screen
either. Like, I've got every reason for leaving on Twitch right
now. >> The no chat is for Twitch, brother. >> What
are you talking about?
>> Well, I don't do that [__] so
>> it's fine. Go off. It's fine.
Yeah, just listen to it's just like it's gay as hearing this
guy be like, "Oh, no. Actually, it's fine when we do doxing because
uh Brandon Buckingham was >> Hey, I didn't do it. >> Why
is he epic? Why is he epic? Cuz he's Cuz what? Cuz he faked the
hospital. >> Cuz he's suck. That's why. >> Yeah,
but Okay. So, if someone sucks, you just do them.
>> Pretty much. >> No, I mean, I'm joking there.
But like like I don't know. Like in this situation, I think situations
matter. like context matters to some extent, right? When Destiny's
doxing people, he's doxing people that are accusing him rightfully
so of,
you know, holding like child porn or whatever of like people
that he's like, you know, uh had conversations with when they
were like 17 and and stuff like that.
But then you have to understand
whether you're right or not.
>> It's no it and it can't be that because there will be
situations like the Destiny one where not all the proof was even
public and you can't even know like categorically who's right
and who's wrong. Right? So if he can convince his audience that
he's right then he's just green lit do like he can green light
to all of them like doxing and just total >> well I'm not
saying it's okay. I'm not saying it's okay. I'm just explaining
why when I looked at it, I was like, "This is epic." Like, this
is just cool. >> Well, you're saying you can't pretend
you have you have a moral problem with it, but it sounds like
you're saying an emotional reason and then just working backwards
and saying, "Actually, my emotional reason is my moral reason."
>> Well, I just think that it's different like in certain
situations because when >> Des my friend and >> No,
it's not about being friends. It's about whether he's right or
not. Right. If if Tom legitimately somebody and they're just
doxing the person accusing him of that [__] right?
And it looks pretty bad and there's no reason to do that, then
it's bad, right? But if this is some stupid crazy just saying
crazy lies about him and stuff like that, right? Why am I supposed
to feel upset? I don't get it. >> So if someone lies about
you, you can dox So what's the standard? What's the standard?
If someone lies about you can dox them. >> I don't think
you should dox people. But I just think it's a different there's
a different like emotional response when it comes >> to
but there's a rule there's a rule is we just want the rule >> right
cuz you what you should do listen >> I I might feel emotional
and want to punch some in the face when she like talks to me
at a bar. Okay. But emotionally I want to do that principally
punching women in the face is wrong. So like I have to hold myself
back right. I have to hold back that emotion and and state my
actual or hold to my actual principle. Just don't do violence
on people cuz they're talking [__] about you.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah, I get what you're saying. I don't know. I just Who cares
about the principles? It's just funny. It's funny. It's funny.
It's fine. >> It's not It's funny when it's like It's >> Aren't
you a Christian? Aren't you a Christian or
>> Okay. So, what do you mean you don't care about the
principles? Uh
>> Uh I just I don't know. It's It's I think it's fine
like when are lying about you.
Yeah. Is that that sounds very Christian to me, bro?
Isn't Brandon Bakio meant to be one of these Christian losers,
too? Isn't Tom Pal around with all these like Brandon Herrera
Grifter [__] suckers?
>> By the way, >> I don't know anything about that.
>> I am almost positive in my mind that uh Turkey Tom and
Tone are hanging out. That's got to be a thing. Feel like that's
got to be a thing.
no What do you mean by that? >> It's like the same posting.
Now, your skits are posting. >> No, it's like the same
adjacent, right? It's Brandon Herrera. It's all the the gun people.
>> Yeah, babe. Bro, Teto's not actually like friends with
those guys. Come on >> You don't think so? >> No.
No one's friends with Te, bro. Come
>> I Okay.
>> The only people friends with Tone are like Pegasus and
West because they don't have to actually hang out with them.
They just like online.
>> Those guys [__] suck. Yeah. Okay. I
I could try to hold you to stuff. I get what you're saying like
emotionally and I'm like
I I understand what you're saying emotionally but it's basically
>> you don't you don't think like people should live their
lives
being like good people who have like beliefs that they stand
by. You think that's a good thing to do? Yeah. It's a good thing
for you to do. >> Yeah, of course they should do that.
But it's like I just think in >> but not but not when it's
like some nasty on the internet who's telling lies about your
friend. Not not then. >> I just can't get mad at it, right?
Like I just >> You don't have to get mad at it. You can
just like recognize, hey, that's wrong. Brandon Buckingham is
like kind of a piece of >> It's crazy. I think >> it's
not the first time he's done. >> I think there's an element
to that why I like it though, right? There's an element to like,
wow, he really just did that. He did the thing that you're not
supposed to do. Like that is wild and he did it to like such
an unlikable that has been objectively telling lies about just
me personally along with Tom. I mean, she's been lied about me
on the forum and too, she's been talking about how we all deserve
to get hit or whatever, right? When she's the only one who ends
up getting hit, I'm going to laugh. I'm going to be like, "Wow."
>> Exactly how people justify the Ethan that are just >> You
want to know great way to not get Don't go in a [__]
>> That's exactly how people >> Sorry, I don't feel
any sympathy for these people and they go on the internet and
they say mean things about me and they
don't [__] talk. Okay. >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Fair enough. >> Come on, dude. But look, I'm I'm
explaining myself emotionally. I'm trying to explain to you guys
how I really feel. >> No, no, no. I I get I'm sorry what
you're saying you feel but it's like it's just it feels like
pulling teeth trying to get like the the belief the position
the opinion plus just the feeling you know
>> yeah sometimes you got to just suspend that just to
have a little bit of fun right like >> I don't think it's
admitted like very quickly [laughter] just real quick he admitted
very very quickly that like the principle was wrong it's just
like you should probably have a better mapping of what you want
to allow versus like what your principles are. Like you shouldn't
say >> there's commentary and morals and then there's just
real life. You know what I mean? Like I do think there's like
a little bit of a
Okay. No, this is it's not commentary morals. It's morals, dude.
It's like is it okay to dox people? Is it okay to go and post
someone's person identifying information online for the purpose
of directing harassment? >> My position on docking has
always been there. I don't have a I've never even in the past
like five six years ago if you were to hear my position on doxing
I've never had the position of it is never okay to dox people
if people are doxing you I've always been okay with like counter
doxing and stuff like that I've explicitly said that and stuff
like that if people are going after livelihood and stuff like
that I've always said and you can pull up clips of this I don't
know where you'd go to find it >> okay what's your reasoning
for being okay with like counterdoxing then so why is counterdoxing
okay >> because they set the morals for what they allow
to do to you. So you can treat those same people, you can just
hold them to their own moral standard. If they say, "Okay, doxing
you is okay." Then you can be like, "Okay, sure. Let's live by
your worldview. Now I do it to you." Right.
>> Okay. So if someone like you, it's okay to rap them
back.
>> I think Jesus said that, right?
>> I'm pretty sure that's literally what's in the Bible.
They say, >> "Yeah, you should
>> engage in
against people."
[laughter]
>> for sure. >> Well, no. You should have a forgiveness
and you should turn the other way, right? Obviously. >> Well,
well, that's not what you think, though, is it? That's not how
you live. And that's not what you think. >> No, but I don't
think that most people that I encounter are uh are operating
under this like Christian morality, right? I I I I'm very big
on just treating people like how >> I just don't I me personally
I I don't really understand the point in just retribution. Like
if there's a you know I can understand some niche circumstance
>> if somebody's like okay I can do this to you. It's like
okay fair enough. >> That is retribution. That's retribution.
That's what you're saying. >> Yeah. I don't have a big
issue with that. To be honest >> I I have to go back. Okay.
That's a little weird. But I have to go back and just ask you.
You said this commentary morals versus like real life morals.
That feels really weird to me because your commentary morals
are the ones you're trying to put on like other people on the
internet. If you're not willing to live up to those morals, but
you're trying to apply them to other people, that feels super
[__] to me, right? Like you should live up to anything
you're willing to commentate
>> Those aren't your real life morals. >> You should
be living up to that. >> You can say it's commentary morals
versus real life morals, but those aren't your real life morals
either. Let's be serious. You're going to I guarantee there are
a million examples in real life where you're you're saying this
exact same [__] where you're like, "Oh, who gives
a man? Who gives a man?" You know?
Well, who gives a with doxing and stuff like that? >> About
like some retributive retributive act that you'd usually be against
if it wasn't preceded by some wrongdoing that you think should
be punished.
>> basically when you like somebody, you'll justify any
bad thing they do. Like if it's somebody you like against somebody
you don't like, you justify essentially >> Not not in every
case. Obviously, not in every case, but that there's like a >> it
seems like basically you're just displaying a blank. just like
okay to >> to like shift really noticeably.
>> I I just think there's like a difference of perspective.
It's like uh to an extent it's like when it comes to the perspective
of the people around you when you know the situation more than
like the average person, right? You see what's going on from
the inside, you can sympathize more with retribution,
retri uh acts of retribution, right? that you wouldn't necessarily
uh be in support of from the outside looking in on a different
situation with people that you don't know. So, I think there's
probably some truth to that.
>> Almost call it barbarian retributive violence, I think.
[laughter] >> Right. Yeah. You're just saying like all
you're just saying there is like yeah, people have biases and
you should just have your bias and never try and counter or examine
it in any way. It's just
they just basically it it's like saying yeah it's good to be
irrational, right?
>> Um I think a certain level of irrationality can be suspended
when it comes to your friends because loyalty is an important
value.
>> Okay. But loyalty isn't just like >> but it depends
like what they're doing like if they're if they're if they're
doing some horrible [__] or they're
Okay. So you're okay stuff like that, right? Obviously loyalty
is when you're okay with your friends doing >> So you're
saying loyalty is when you're okay with your friends doing small
bad things and
>> I think it just depends on a case by case scenario.
You got to look at a situation. You got to be like, okay, is
this just some is this just my friend
or is this something that I should take more seriously?
>> dude. I think you displayed a perfect level of loyalty
when you were like, "Hey, I've seen this stuff that's out on
Tom. I need more proof before I say anything bad or do anything
take any action against him. I think that was loyalty. I think
other people wanted to cancel podcast with him, wanted to distance
from him. I think that was a lack of loyalty, right? Before all
the evidence was in >> Yeah. Other people. >> And
I think I think that was loyalty, but loyalty shouldn't be. >> You
know, now my my friend has like obviously conclusively done something
wrong and I'm going to say that it's not that bad. I think >> Well,
I think it depends on what they're doing that's wrong. You know,
like I said, if my friends are lying or scamming people or people
over or people for that matter, obviously >> people like
>> doxing people.
>> Uh, it depends on the situation, I think. [laughter]
So why is stealing some from someone wrong but doxing them isn't
like
>> uh you're saying like these things were like unequivocally
doxing you're like >> stealing I think it's like an inherently
like dishonest action when you're stealing from somebody whereas
with doxing it could be like justified
>> doxing literally has malicious is like in the definition
of doxing it's like for the purpose of harassment but you mean
sometimes it's like >> it doesn't make any sense it doesn't
make any sense You're saying you're saying you're just saying
bias is okay. Have bias. That's like
>> that's not necessarily what I'm saying. >> That
feels like there's no justifiable.
There definitely would be, but >> there definitely could
be justifiable doxing. Just don't say that. That's >> Sorry.
I'm going to also fall back to moderating because I don't want
Augie to be 2v1 the whole time. So, >> sorry. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. >> Go ahead. could do a couple. >> Now, I just
be clear, I'm having a little bit of a thought experiment here
just to, you know, >> I figured you basically you basically
Yeah, you you know said, >> "Oh, I'm okay with it." And
now you're just like, you know, testing the argument really.
But
>> well, cuz I am >> You basically described how
you felt like how you reacted and then >> I am describing
how I feel and I do have I did have a reaction like I didn't
feel bad at all when it happened. Right. So I am talking to you
guys a little bit just to sort of ground me a bit and hear the
other side and stuff like that, right? Um it is just a bit hard
for me to look at like what these people have done. U and admittedly
it is still one of my friends. So obviously I'm completely like
ideologically in this whole conversation because it's Tom, it's
one of my friends, right? So it's like when I see somebody go
after one of my friends in this dishonest way, right? And then
he is just objectively proving that everything they've said for
the last two weeks is [__] as they tried to like
terrorize and ruin his life and destroy his business that he
spent the last whatever decade building and stuff like that.
When I see horrible [__] happen to them and I celebrate
I do want to explore why I feel that way. So there is like a
little bit of like but I also do feel that way genuinely. So
I don't >> what additional benefit is gained by doxing
them. >> I think it puts someone to evil. If I were if
I were to play complete devil's advocate, I do think it puts
them on an uneven playing field, right? >> How? What do
you mean? >> Because both of them are public figures now.
It's not just an anon versus
that's not quite I understand what you're sort of saying, but
both their names on the record, I guess you mean? But like what
>> Okay, I don't know what difference that quite makes.
>> Like what are you aiming to do with that? What what
does that do? Well, she anything that she says about Tom now,
she has to say that like as a public person now with like a real
identifiable background. She can't just say whatever crazy she
wants. She has to say that as her as a person, not just as like
some sort of entity on a website. So, I do think that that puts
things on a more even playing field. If I were to play Devil's
Advocate, >> so what so what happens off the back of that?
So, now they're both public people. What changes for her now?
I think they have the same certain level of scrutiny around what
they say and how they act online.
Not exactly the same because Tom's like a public figure.
>> Uh because things that you say can reflect back on you
when you try to live like a normal life and you have or you're,
you know, going to school, you're trying to get a job, you're
trying to be a regular person. Like just like how when Tom dates
these crazy and they can just look up anything that's happened
in his life on KBI farms. It's the same thing for her, right?
>> So, it does just feel like the goal is the only the
benefit is it damages her
>> Well, it just makes her have to take into take more
seriously what she puts out on the internet. Right.
>> Well, the damaging stuff is already out there, so that
doesn't we're past that
>> Right. But she can say whatever crazy she wants as an
anonymous person. Obviously, that holds more weight if she's
like a publicly identifiable person. Right.
Was
she really anonymous? >> But how do our claims hold more
weight >> She was anonymous before
her claims hold more weight because she has to sort of, you know,
be more I guess she has to be more Look, I'm playing devil's
advocate here, but she has to be more serious about what she's
saying. She can't just say crazy. >> But what I'm saying
is is that like what I'm trying to get at is it doesn't seem
like there is really any additional benefit. The the only thing
that happens here is it damages her life. It's just like that
that's the only goal. >> And Tom's Tom's already proven
his point. He's already to to any extent that he can. He has
repaired the reputational damage. The only way he could maybe
go further is by maybe like trying to sue her for defamation,
which doesn't require doxing. That would just be, you know, her
name would be in the public filings, but it doesn't require you
posting on Twitter. >> Yeah. He already knows her identity.
>> Yeah. I don't think it was necessary. Just to be clear,
I don't think it >> it's not just unnecessary. It's like
there is no additional benefit and it kind of just makes Tom
and his friends look bad. >> Yeah, I can definitely see
that. >> It's like so what? This follows her around in
her life. You you never see that, you know, you're never going
to get to sit there and have the shard and freer of, you know,
not that this would ever happen, but like imagine her getting
rejected from a job or a college place or whatever the um because
of this. You never get to see that. It's just oh, in the moment,
yeah, [__] you. And then then what? you kind of just
look bad anyway.
>> Yeah. I mean, there is some part of me that's like uh
I don't like the fact that you know there is like an uneven playing
field with public figures where it's like if you as like an anonymous
person have a bad interaction with a public figure or perceived
bad interaction. You can just say whatever crazy [__]
you want completely protected by your own anonymity while this
person has to suffer from the consequences of what you're saying,
what you're putting onto them forever possibly. Right. So what
do So do you think that commentary channels, anonymous commentary
channels should be unmasked?
>> Why not? Why? They're they're talking crazy about all
these bigger content creators who have so much to lose. They've
already got their docers out
>> No, I don't think that doxing should be a normal stand.
Just to be clear, like I'm not saying >> but but they say
but they're making
in a specific context. I think you can't just look at it as like
it's either all bad or it's all good. You have to look at the
specific situation. teasing out the what is the rule? What awareness
is it? Okay, it feels like
>> it's it is basically just Well, when it's one of your
friends who has a girlfriend that wrongs them, then it's okay.
That basically feels like what your standard is.
>> Well, if it was somebody else that was wronged by a
woman or something, if Slazo, I know people don't like when people
make references to old commentary dramas here, but it I'm just
saying >> arguably arguably a response that makes it sound
even worse. So you could go, >> oh my god, when a woman,
it's just like, okay, so is it just when women do it? Is it just
when women wrong a man? You can do only women only [laughter]
standard. Yeah, exactly. Men should only be able to dox women.
>> No, but I'm just saying like um
like I do think you have to look at the situations like individually
and understand why did this happen? What is going on here?
And you have to determine was this like not necessarily a justified
use of force or was this an understandable use of force and then
that can overall in you know uh help you interpret your opinion
on the whole situation right it's not just all black or white
like all doxing is good all doc
usually to me the the whether some use of force is justified
or whatever is >> determined or utility by the utility
of what it's going to achieve. If the only thing you're >> I
think the utility, let's be clear, the utility here is just to
[__] your up. Let's be honest, right? >> Yeah.
So exposed to PII for the purpose of like harassment maliciously
like to [__] up, right? For retribution. >> So
it's just doxing with no justification like
>> Right. I I think that that's true. I think that that's
>> doxing because I hate this person.
>> Yeah. Not necessarily because I hate this person, but
because she's trying to ruin my friend's life,
>> which I Yeah, I feel like you just >> I feel like
you probably hate people who try to ruin your friend's lives
with lies, right? I feel like that's you maybe you say hate is
the wrong word or something, but >> it's pretty much like
you really dis you intensely dislike the people who try to ruin
your friends life with um malicious lies. Right.
>> So, because you intensely dislike them, doxing them
is good.
And you well no >> I didn't say it was good Tom. >> Maybe
I said it was good or I said maybe I said it was before. I don't
think I said that but I'm >> or something >> but
I said that I can understand the human intention behind it. Behind
it. I can understand the human intention behind it and that when
I saw it I didn't feel bad. That's what I said just to be clear.
>> Sure. Sure. Sure.
>> Yeah. Um,
man, that's uh that's >> it feels like we're jumping back
and forth between two different things. So, you don't So, you
don't think it's justified? You think it's a bad action or not?
>> I don't personally It's a bad action like objectively
to like dox people um in this specific situation. I don't It's
hard for me to see it that way. Uh I gotta be real. Um, I mean,
she was, you know, it seems like she wanted to roll around in
the mud and then she got exactly what comes with that and now
she's wants to cry about it.
It's hard for me to feel sympathy for >> This is literally
this is the nonsense argument that I hate where you just people
fall back to doing, >> oh, I just can't feel sympathy for
it's just like it's not an argument. It's not an argument. It's
not a point. It's not an opinion. It's not a take. It's just
you like literally saying I don't like this person so bad thing
justified. That's what that's all it's like the >> actually
the reasoning for like
>> all bad action basically. It's like
war crimes tons of things is the justification for all of it.
It's like ultimately comes down to actually these people just
suck. They deserve it. >> It just feels good.
>> Yeah. Again, I just go back to the Ethan Klein thing
because that to me seems like so obvious a comparison. It's just
the um like the the lawsuits against denims where everybody is
is justifying that lawsuits against denims cuz denim sucks. Denims
is cringe. And it's like, no, this is a guy who's like dox this
person's real identity as suing them, trying to get them to stop
talking about him. Like that's explicitly the goal there. And
then people will let it go and they'll be like, you know what,
denim sucks. Denims is cringe. I'm fine with this. It's like,
okay, well I don't know what what are we supposed to do, man?
Like if you use that justification that that justifies it just
opens all kinds of crazy. Yeah. No, I see what you're saying.
That's a valid argument. That's a valid argument. That's worthy
of consideration for me. Definitely. I see what you're saying
there.
um shifting gears. Apparently Nick implied that you guys knew
a bunch of stuff for ages but played dumb. Still on >> Like
what?
>> So that's not a no.
>> Well, what do you say? So you [laughter] >> Well,
you got to tell me it was specifically what happened. >> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Uh I don't know. I just got a message saying, "Ask Oie how long
he had inside info from Tom since Dior implied he knew for a
while but played dumb."
>> What do you know? >> Did you guys know like did
you [laughter] guys know that
proven?
>> What's up? >> I want to know. Did you guys know
that Tom had this all like laid out like that he was coming back
with like this video? You guys have a good idea that this was
coming out?
Did you get to see like the evidence way
>> Not way beforehand. I saw I did see this video like
a few days ago, I will admit, but I mean, not like weeks ago.
>> Yeah, it was obvious that Dioro was baiting on stream
the other night. >> I mean, is that like terrible? I don't
>> I mean, I think it looks super weird when Dioro immediately
jumps to lying about this girl trying to dox him or whatever
the >> I mean, you don't think she was fishing for information?
She was trying to speak to the girl, but that's not Doc saying
Dior is lying about that to try and make this Brandon Buckingham
thing seem okay.
>> She was uh actively looking for that girl's information
though, right? >> Yeah, but that's not it's not doxing
to go and speak to someone. >> You don't think she was
going to post that on the on the thread? >> I have no reason
to believe she's going to post on thread. Why do you think she
was going to do that?
>> Why do you think she was going to do
>> Cuz she's posting anything else she could. She'd never
post anyone else's name without their permission as far as I'm
aware. Anyone that said they wanted to be private was not posted.
>> Like uh like who? >> She had there were like screenshots
posted that were censored from like Instagram DMs and
>> I haven't seen her post anyone that was meant to be
private. >> We also went down this whole line where it's
like totally fine for commentary channels to post embarrassing
information about people, but they all avoid posting like identifying
information for a reason, right? It's like the big big difference.
So like obviously posting docs I you would assume because she's
familiar with these spaces that she knows that posting docs is
like a red line for a lot of people and I just haven't seen any
indication >> I [laughter] didn't even well but I didn't
even um well actually for her probably on Kiwi Farms if I didn't
know this but if what Queen is saying is correct that she actually
censored identities to not expose people like I do think >> I
don't know which girl it was I I know there were DMs that were
getting posted where these girls were reaching out to people
and getting information and there was someone that didn't want
their name on there or whatever. and they had scratched it out
with black
whatever in the you know screen. >> Why do you think she
was so curious about who Dior's girlfriend is? >> She wanted
to get more information >> but not to post it. >> Was
she
said why >> she's looking for who Tom cheated on her with
at VidCon, right? That's why she was looking for that. >> Yeah,
she was trying to get She was trying to get information. She
was going to post
Wait, wait. Wasn't the VidCon girl the girl that Tom cheated
on her with? Was that the same person? Or am I wrong on >> No.
I I hope Tom didn't cheat on her with Nick's girlfriend. >> No,
no, no. >> Tom likes him skinny. So, >> hold on now.
I I The VidCon girl I assumed
was
somebody that Tom had hooked up with that knew Nick Dioro's girlfriend,
right? Or am I completely getting this
>> I I'm not sure about the exact >> Apparently somebody
affiliated with Destiny or something.
>> Yeah. Oh, yeah. That was it. They were trying to figure
out who this person affiliated with Destiny was that um apparently
Dorio's girlfriend would have known or whatever the apparent
Tom cheated with. But anyway, the point is there is no indication
anywhere in that thread that she was going to post docks. Nothing
said there indicate she was going to post dox and Dior comes
out the day this girl is getting doxed lying about her trying
to dox him
or is a girlfriend or whatever. The
that's weird as [__] I have a different interpretation
just by how I know how Kiwi Farms culture works, but uh I I I
definitely agree that there's no proof that she was had an intention
to dox her, but I do think that that's probably what she wanted
to do. But I guess that's just an opinion. I don't know. >> There's
just like no indication of that at any other point in the post.
>> I mean, she said these people deserve to get nuked.
She was actively looking for information. Everyone was going
to her release it. They wanted her to release
information to form a bridge or sorry to form a rift between
Dioro and Tom because if this ex exposed Dior's girlfriend, Dior
would then get to Tom for allowing this to even happen by just
association, right? They were pushing her to do that and she
was engaging with those posts. So, it seems like I don't know.
I I could definitely I agree there's no evidence of it, but like
it definitely seems like that was a strong motivator. Uh at least
in my opinion, but I don't know.
>> Okay. Why is it so hard? So, in fact, why do you think
the decision was made in Nick's head to instead of simply say
this girl's weird as harassing people, trying to harass people
I know and get information out of them to to cause problems between
me and my friends? She's just involving random offline people
that have nothing to do with it for no reason. Why did he not
just say that? Why did he instead choose to say, "She's doxing
me. She's trying to dox me, my girlfriend, whatever."
>> Because he probably felt like that's what she was trying
to do on Kiwi Farms. >> But that's not substantiated. And
the other thing is
>> Yeah, but I can see how he'd come to that conclusion.
And I know that sounds >> You really think he came You
think he seriously came to that conclusion? I >> don't
think it's dishonest. Okay, >> I do believe that. >> Well,
I I guess you know,
>> like, let me see the post that she was saying. She told
me the girl was apparently a long-term girlfriend he had known
since elementary school. So, she's dropping like little details.
All these freaks and the ones covering for him deserve to get
nuked. She's responded to somebody telling her. >> But
is that Hold on. Is that information that wasn't out before?
I could have sworn I'd heard that before and I don't know where
information from >> the that went to elementary school
that Nick was like with somebody who's like that that was his
girlfriend at VidCon. People speculated and that people knew
that he'd been
saying just my friend. >> I know it sounds crazy. I don't
know anything about Nick Dioro's girlfriend. So I don't know
like how long they were >> I just could have sworn I'd
heard that before and I but I don't know if I'm just like made
that up. It's maybe I'm getting deja vu from something else.
>> I don't I don't remember about that. So, I like I've
got my eye. >> I'll go deja vu for now. >> Sure.
Sure. Sure. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. I do think Yeah. It's just um >> Yeah.
I don't think that's an honest conclusion, Nick Drew. I really
don't. I think um you know, I don't if you honestly believe it.
>> I actually don't know why this person in the thread
said it. The person in the thread that says like, "Oh, you're
just going to dox people." And this this was like where somebody
in the thread said, "You're doxing people." He said, "Apparently
a long-term girlfriend. He's known since elementary school."
I unless you want to say that's the doxing.
Somebody accuses her in the thread and that doesn't make sense
to me either.
I don't know. >> Yeah, it's just a self victimization thing
trying to equivocate and Nick knows that >> that's real
close to getting her docks. Oh, do people like know where Nick
went to school or something?
He's on Aiden's stream by the way.
>> Is that That's where we've gotten to. Nick is now going
on stream. >> Nick called. He really does look wer. [laughter]
He really does lookers now. Damn, he's fully embracing. >> Okay,
another reason why I'm on Aiden's stream is he what? >> Here's
another reason
why I'm pro. This is another reason why I changed my position
on doxing is because you guys turned on my friend Aiden and I
think Aiden was cool for doxing.
>> You guys bullied him out of the community.
[laughter] >> We didn't bully him out at all. I talked
to him like two days ago. >> We backstabbed him in London.
That's what you said. We all backstabbed. Even though I've literally
tried I've tried so hard. >> Your stream is brutal against
him, dude. Like, come [laughter] on. >> I I understand.
Look, that's how I talk. That's how I talk. [gasps] >> Yeah,
maybe it's a British
retribution for Aiden leaking things about him. Queen was like
retributively. >> To be fair, I don't even anything. I
I leak like, "Oh, he has bad table manners. Oh, we fuck." >> No,
all I remember was I watched that stream. I was in the chat engaging
with it. I thought it was hilarious. And then the longer that
it went on, the more I was like, "Oh, is this like aen stream?
I don't even know where I am right now." >> I was just
uh I was, you know, we're making content. >> Yeah, true.
>> We're recouping costs from that weekend, >> Well,
wait. If Nick's on Aiden, like, can we watch that? Like, >> I
think he's off now. >> Threw it up on stream
or anything. You
>> I didn't see where he was on. >> I think they
were just talking about tag time. It doesn't look I don't know.
>> Oh, okay. Unfortunate.
Too bad. I see >> We could just get Nick in here. We could
just hash this all out right now. We could just wanted to join
up on the stream. We could hash this all out right >> Would
be totally fine with it. >> You know, when I have a disagreement
with someone, I like to just, you know, talk to them about it
and really get down to exactly what's going on. That's me personally.
>> Someone says all can just say what you want with your
chest. I mean, I feel like I am I say what I want or I say how
I feel honestly to my own detriment. Like that's what >> I
don't think you said anything that's like uh you know >> yeah
dishonest. I feel like you're you're literally owning the position
that you even slightly disagree with logically in your head and
just be like this is how I feel though and I don't know why I
feel that way. >> Well the way that I come to my own conclusions
with things is I just say how I feel and then I talk with people
about it and then I come up with a more fortified conclusion
afterwards. So that's what I'm doing with you guys right now
because you guys will push me on.
So
>> yeah, fair enough. All right,
let's um Dude, why can someone Where's Hellbent?
Hellbent is the only channel of communication we have now.
>> Only got to ask this only >> tell Hellbent. Uh
no, actually actually technically Aiden's asked that quite a
few times trying to avoid. Okay, so
>> all right, we we just need Hellbent to get a message
to Nicholas Dioro right now. Tell him to hop on the stream. Although
he might be streaming, too. He's definitely not going to do that.
If he's live, there's no way he'll talk to >> I go cross
stream.
[laughter] >> Yeah, he No, he won't do that. He would never
He would never want us on stream with him while he's talking
to his audience. Now he's definitely live >> I got to be
careful. He's still live. >> I'm on dangerous ground right
now. I've lost my Tommy C connection last time I >> Yeah,
that's that's tough. That sucks, man. That's >> that's
a rough one, man. >> I've been crying all night.
>> That's you you're you're in trouble now. Okay. I heard
that guy took out Chudlo Logic. I think you're next. >> Yeah.
Uh Tommy took Chud down to the below 1k tier. It was it was a
brutal decimation. [laughter]
It's very very rough, man.
has has Chud is Chud even looking at this stuff? Chud went on
vacation. Okay. Did Did they wait for Chud to go on vacation
to drop this? By the way, what do you think, Kaggi? What do you
think of that conspiracy theory
>> that Tom W
on his way to Vietnam? >> He was very quick to accuse me
of sweeping. Uh-oh. [laughter]
>> Wait, what did he think you were sweeping by doing?
>> No, I'm just trolling. He I I do believe that he was
more calling out Nick >> when I look back on that. Uh,
but he was definitely very like he's like, "Oh, I hope Augie
streams about this. I better hope he's not blah blah blah." >> Yeah,
but it felt very tongue and cheek with you. It felt very, you
know, it wasn't like >> Well, I was bantering with him
in the DM. I don't give a [__] Like I I was >> I
just you know I don't know if you saw what I was talking about
but obviously you know it seemed totally like the big >> I
did watch your coverage. I did watch your coverage of our conversation.
I agreed with that. So >> awesome. Awesome. >> Look
at Nick's stream title. Uh okay. Turkey Tom responded. We are
so back. Why is no one else covering this? O
[laughter] I think
he's been go openly going after Chud on this stream by the way.
Ooh,
>> I did hear there was he did. >> How do you How
do you do that when you're like too get in the call? I just like
don't understand why he even gets off like taking shots if he's
like too actually hash any of it out. Is that the same [__]
that Willie Mac does?
>> Wow, that definitely wasn't for me. But yeah. Okay,
I agree with that. I I do >> Wait, was that Sorry, was
that for me? Like am I supposed to answer >> supposedly
for you? I think you >> Oh, I mean I
said we should get >> I am very pro talking to people.
I'm very pro debate. That's why I'm here right now. I mean I'm
very
>> I I uh if I had things my way, if I was the content
god, I would control all the debates. So I mean >> I tried
to get Willie Mack to debate Queen last summer. That's what started
to form my bridge with Willie Mack. So,
I mean, I don't answer for Nick. He can do it. He can do whatever
he wants. I don't really answer for him.
>> Yeah. I don't
I I just don't understand how anybody's still standing with Willy
M guy. This guy sucks. Okay. Especially if you're going to stand
behind the the like doxing by
Brandon Buckingham. It's like, oh, doxing wasn't even a problem
for you guys. So, there's like literally no reason for that video
to have been made. Dude, I'm literally so I'm so excited to see
where Willie M goes with his content. So stop sort of dying down.
I literally like he's had two flop videos on Candace Owens. >> Not
the Candace. It's not the Candace >> Yeah, exactly. Two
flop videos on Candace Owens and that over anyway. So like what's
next? What's next? I would love Here's what I would love. I would
for
start doing a series of videos on Fuentes and start fighting
with Gropers. That would just >> bring bring a smile to
my face. [laughter] Nothing else.
>> Holy [__] That would be so good. He that
would actually make sense, too, because he does take shots at
Fuentes >> He goes after anyone going after the
>> Well, yeah. Well, he also does these like low IQ arguments.
He's like, "Is Fuentes gay?" It's like I understand like people
think Fuentes is gay, but like when I see Willie Mack make those
kinds of arguments, it just comes across as so low IQ and just
lowlevel engagement with anything Fuentes has to say. Like obviously
I think we all know if Fuentes got into a call with Willie Mack,
he would just run circles around that guy mentally.
So >> I mean Hassan did.
>> I don't think I ever watched Hassan Willie go at it.
Actually, >> you should you should give it a go one day.
It's funny. It's so funny. >> I think I was off the internet
at that
Did he get uh he got raped? >> He goes on and Hassan's
like he's just released a video on Hassan and Hassan calls him
on to his stream and he's like let's debate and he's like Willie
what what points what criticisms do you have for me? And Willy's
like oh I don't know I have to check my video
>> Auggie. Did you feel like Chud was accusing you of not
condemning Tom? >> Yeah. So I was just asking you what
did you think Chud was cuz when Chud was complaining about people
Yeah. You're not echoing anymore. when he was complaining about
people, I got the impression he was saying people are acting
like this didn't happen when it's like massive drama and you
should just cover it and put your opinion on the record. That's
the impression I got. Did you get a different impression? >> How
is this? I'm just testing. Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry. >> When
it comes to Chud or whatever, right? I did get the impression
he was doing a little bit of like a cabal call out initially,
right? Because historically, I mean, everyone knows there's been
past drama around Tom that, you know, we didn't cover and stuff
like that, right? And that that kind of like built this sort
of reputation, this idea that any negative story that happens
around Turkey Tom will just go ignored and undisussed by the
community because we have some sort of like financial contract
with Turkey Tom, right? I did kind of feel like Chud was playing
into that. Looking back on it though, I think it was more so
a call out at Nick rather than me.
Uh just because I'm so like, you know, distant from this whole
scene. I mean, I I check in from time to time, but you know,
I I kind of I'm a little bit on a different path right now, right?
So, like I do think that it was kind of a distant call out. It
was more of a call out on Nick, but I do I did see him in the
Discord. He was getting very antsy about sweeping and he was
like, "It's all going to be going to cover this blah blah blah."
I think he was applying a little bit of pressure on me to cover
it, which I mean, I found to be ridiculous because of course
I was going to cover it. >> Okay. But the impression I've
been getting is that people think Chud was saying that this is
like a big deal and Tom's guilty so you have to cover this. But
I never got that impression once that he was like, "Oh, Tom's
very guilty. This proves he's like a you have to cover this,
but you're not going to cuz you're sweeping." I think it was
like it's embarrassing for Tom. So I hope you do cover it because
hugely
>> I I agree with that. But like if Chud is if his opinion
of the allegations was this was a nothing burger, but he's at
the same time outraged and nobody's covering it. >> That
does kind of feel weird to me. >> Well, it's not a nothing
burger no matter what because the information is like embarrassing
and and like sensational and it's like it's it's content at the
end of the day. It's like it is great content whether it's whether
the extremities whether the actual things you would condemn or
not are true, right?
>> Yeah. And it's even better content now that Tom like
refuted everything. Right. Tom came out and just like blew out
this allegation in a way nobody has in years. I can't remember
the last time somebody blew out an allegation like this, right?
>> It's like George not found here. It's like George not
found here sort of sort of allegation, right? I'd say >> I
think it might be even stronger than >> but yeah, it is.
>> Let me ask you guys this question cuz this is like a
little bit of a thing I've been like also doing a little bit
of thought experimentation with. So, do content creators have
an obligation to humiliate and make fun of their friends? Like
if their friends are in drama and it's not severe,
>> but it's also embarrassing, right? Do they have an obligation
to just make fun of and humiliate their friends on their own
platform?
>> If if your whole thing is humiliating, embarrassing
other people, then I think generally it's good practice to to,
you know, apply that evenly. >> But even your own friends,
like why can't you just be like, I like making fun of people
that I hate and that I don't like. Why can't you draw a distinction
between that and your friends? Just like a human being. >> You
can. And if you want if you want your stream to be like, you
know, here's I just sit here and talk about the people I I hate,
then then sure. But there are some people like like Nick who
like to sort of build themselves like the drama news show and
they very clearly sort of see themselves that way or like Tom,
you know, kind of sees himself like a journalist. you know, he
he very clearly kind of takes him views himself that way and
he's gone after people like West Jeep before for stories up and
and they all do that. They all go after people for stories up,
being inconsistent with their friends or, you know, uh sweeping
when well one of these lefties has a friend doing something embarrassing,
whatever the I do agree like if your friend is like hurting people,
scamming people, lying, whatever the [__] right?
You should call them out. If you're not going to call them out
for doing stuff like that, then you know you're a loser. But
if your friend just had an embarrassing moment, like he had like
a cringy breakup with a girl or there was some weird like relationship
drama or just something cringy that happened that isn't like
breaking news, like they didn't do anything wrong or bad, but
it is like humiliating and funny. Do the friends of these people
have to cover stuff like that >> or can they get away with
not covering it because they're just like, you know what, I just
don't want to humiliate my friends. Like, I like these people.
>> I think it's difficult because the condemnation and
the humiliation from
>> especially people like Nick and Tom is so similar, if
you know what I mean. I This looks really bad, dude. This looks
really bad. That's like a Nick stream. That's and so the condemnation,
the humiliation are like the same thing in in this content.
>> Yeah. I don't think you have a reason that you have
to cover it. I personally think you just go, I know this person
too much or I'm too close to this person. I can't even cover
it fairly, so I'm not going to. I think you do that. I think
as long as you don't downplay,
>> You like can do that. You can do that. I'm saying like
why would I would you >> just speaking just speaking clearly
or whatever right >> best practices >> the initial
the original Tom drama which was like the Kai like Liam thing
or whatever right I never covered that and Tom never asked me
it's not like he never you know he never asked me like don't
cover this or whatever right I made my own conscious decision
not to cover that because it was just I what I looked at it as
was just cringy relationship drama between him and another YouTuber
and I didn't want to get involved in that right this new recent
stuff like the allegations that came out against him by these
girls. When these allegations first dropped, the first thing
I did was I, you know, I I called Dior and I was like, "We have
to cover this. Like, this cannot be uncovered otherwise it's
just going to look too bad." You know what I mean? Like, we have
to review this honestly. Um, so I think there's a difference
between these two types of stories, but is that like a fair take
or is that cucked? I think it's I'm just like I'm not 100% sure
what your standards have been. I just know what I've seen of
Nick.
So I don't know. It sounds fair enough. It could be fair enough,
but it just depends how you've sort of acted because the
it just is like so much Nick like same thing with like so we
had this argument like 5 minutes ago where it's like um you start
talking about oh I don't feel bad for these people. something
Nick says all the time. And then the the other one is this looks
so bad. And when the whole stream every day is just these emotional
arguments that aren't actually condemnations, but a phrase like
condemnations,
how do you draw the line between your friend doing something
humiliating, that's bad optics, and your friend doing something
condemnable in terms of like applying standards evenly? Because
your condemnation is just saying this looks bad, you look stupid
right now, whatever the [__]
That's all Nick's capable of doing. That's all he ever does.
>> you're back open, Quan. You're like opening up again.
Reverb a little bit.
>> Guys, I'm in my stream or just on J >> I'm guessing
you don't you have a noise gate on OBS, but you don't have a
noise gate here. >> I don't have a noise gate in OBS. >> I
do have a noise gate here. That's why >> Well, slightly
confused cuz no one's mentioning it there.
>> Augie, do you have any response to that? No, I I take
>> I I take into account like what you're saying about
like the emotional arguments. I I do feel like uh
I feel like what I want to say is like there is some level like
do you live your life rigidly by your standards and your principles
or do you acknowledge that certain situations are different and
there's context and there's human emotions and these things are
valuable not necessarily by just your rigid view of like standards
and morals and ethics cuz it seems like Would you It's like I
can understand. It's like I I can just separate those things
out, right? What is my principle? Can I understand where this
person's coming from when they break their principle or is it
just like totally irrational? You know, there are you can just
pass these things out. >> Like, could you see your friend
doing something that is
logically or morally wrong, but you can sit back and just be
like, "That was kind of awesome and funny, and I'm you're my
friend, and you're my guy, and I support you anyway." Are you
ever in positions like that where you can act like that or are
you always the person who's like, "Nope, this is strictly against
my code of ethics."
>> I I don't know. I just I just don't know what you're
asking. There are other times where >> So I >> I'm
like I get likeis out of something. Yeah, I express cases of
bad things happening sometimes, >> but I would still say
it's wrong. You know, it's I'm not gonna sit there and act like
>> I'm just like I'm asking you kind of like a philosophical
question.
You can feel like this person.
I feel kind of good when this happens.
Why is >> you have to ask what happens when you feel like
somebody's done something wrong? What do you do when somebody's
done something wrong? Because for Quean, I think for for you
guys, like if Tom had done age play, a bunch of you guys were
going to cut him off, right? For Quean, I think he wouldn't have
cut off. wouldn't have cut Tom off for that. He would never have
like hidden that, right? That's the way he looks at it. But when
you have like bad people, people who have done bad things, how
are you going to react personally? And I think a problem with
some of the commentary people is they've created this standard
where when they somebody does a bad thing, we need to kick them
out of the community. We need to cut them off. We can't be associated
with them anymore. Right? I think that's probably the difference
here is you you feel like when we're saying this is really bad,
you might be hearing us saying you have to cut branded bucking
them off. You should never professionally associate with them
again. I do feel like there's like a lot of like >> That's
true. >> I Yeah, I do feel like a lot of pressure of like
cuz in commentary that's kind of how it works. It's like if somebody
does bad thing, you cut them off and stuff like that. And I feel
like if it's if it really works that way, then commentary has
a lot of really old and outdated moral standards that kind of
need a lot more nuance and perspective so that we don't just
cut people off whenever they do something that's bad, but we
have more of like a human conversation around it and just be
like, okay, you know, let's look at the what's going on around
here, you know? Does that make sense?
>> Yeah. I think the I think that's where like a lot of
the issues are coming from is like we can't even have an honest
>> conversation commentary has too much of a rigid >> yeah
I I think we have too much of a rigid view on like a lot of things
such as doxing or even other subjects right like you even mentioned
like the age plan stuff like that maybe you know maybe there
is more
there's like a rigid view on like >> any individual thing
it's the rigid view is like if someone does something bad. You
can't be associated with them versus
>> like simply being able to be associated with someone
like like I'm against doxing in all cases, but if Aiden's like
doxing people, I'm not going to cut him off. I'm going to say
Aiden's a doxer. That's bad. You know that it's like that
>> that [clears throat] simple. But make jokes about >> Yeah.
But I feel like there's like a big expectation with this community
where it's like how could you align yourself or be around people
that do things that you consider as like grave moral sins?
I I agree. Yeah, >> that's the problem. >> Yeah.
Yeah. But that's like a it's not about any of the specific
um topics like it's not about a having too rigid of a stand on
doxy or having too rigid a stand on age play. The too rigid part
is this more core thing that is like everything has to be nuclear.
Everything has to be a cut off. And I don't even think that's
like a standard that other people are imposing. I think that's
a standard that is like self-imposed where you're bas where people
are just being like, "Oh, well, I don't want to get
>> it feels like it's a standard that's almost uh put on
largely by the chat because the chat wants blood. The chat wants
violence. They want
more. >> Some chats are always going to want
no but I think that that logic it starts from the chat and then
the creators look at the chat. They're like, "Oh, my chat wants
war with this person. I'm against this certain thing. Somebody
I know is doing thing. I must go to war with them. And so then
that creates like this rigid moral standard that realistically
nobody can appeal to because everybody is up and they're going
to do things from time to time. They're going to have >> You're
blaming you're blaming the chat, but the chat's always going
to be that. >> I'm not blaming the chat, but I'm I think
that that's where the symptom
>> Sure. Sure. But but ultimately it's on the creator because
you have to just not be aud
I I I understand that
and like I just think if you disavow somebody, like if you disavow
something someone's done, does that mean you can't ever talk
to them anymore? Cuz like I >> I don't think so. >> I
just don't see it that way. >> I I think as long as you're
willing to like never hide the thing they've done, like as long
as you're willing to talk about it openly, somebody makes that
criticism of them, you don't like sweep for them in that instance,
right, then I I just don't think you necessarily have to cut
that person off. I don't think that's necessarily the solution
every time. Depends on what it was, right? >> Yeah. But
then if people do up things and you don't even cut them off and
you're just like ah that person did a wrong thing. It's like
do they get the appropriate level of justice or punishment for
doing the thing that's is a big moral crime in the community.
Then there creates a new problem where it's like people aren't
subjected to enough punishment for doing the things that are
supposed to be like grave moral sense. So it's like then you
have to go back to cutting them off fully to sort of satisfy
that need of punishment.
>> I can I can throw up this video here. This is apparently
um the Dioro segment that where he's talking about um commentary
and [__] >> You guys want to give this a look?
>> Oh my god. >> Let's give it a look. >> Well,
that's where we're at here with the two girls.
>> Um one, thanks for doxing me, Tom.
>> Oh, hold on. I heard somebody join. You guys are both
in. >> Yep. Yep.
>> Thanks for sending his pictures to the owner of Kiwi
Farm. Look, I I don't know. I did my best to censor it. It obviously
did not work. My bad. Uh, I also wouldn't have posted the thing
that Brandon Buckingham posted, but I'm not shedding a single
tear for this wretched [__] And I'll explain why
in a minute. >> Uh, but I'll let that sit for a second.
Also, [snorts] I wasn't bleeding because of my period. And you
know damn well. I told you I liked it cuz I gave in to you hitting
me in the face. You're Tom. You're a So, that's that. Um, and
then I saw this one which actually triggered the out of me. I'll
admit it. >> Oh, sorry. This is him talking about the whole
doxing situation, not just the >> I triggered when I saw
uh Gunt Super Soldier said, "Are you going to address anything
either?" And then and then she goes, "We're going to make a statement
once we both have watched the video and collected our thoughts."
No, you don't.
No. No. No. No. I'm sorry. No. I'm I'm doing like a What is it?
The 24 frames of Nick. Like, no. You don't get to do that.
You don't get to do that. No, you don't get to sit here and wait
while you're live posting and raging in the Kiwi Farms thread
crashing out. I didn't get to. My friends didn't get to. We got
dog >> Can you put this fat 1.25, please? I This is
>> You psychotic [__] By you. You don't get
a break. What are you talking about? Answer now. Oh, no. No.
No. We're talking now. You can talk now. You don't get a break.
We're looking for tips on how to get you on the stream, Nick.
Just come have a
Welcome to the stream. We're just reviewing this. We're taking
a look. If we could have this conversation with you directly,
we wouldn't have to review your stream. We're totally good with
that. I'm good with that. I'll even I'll even set Quimma to like
50% volume. >> We need to cover this right now. Funny thing
I saw today is that
[__] I'm gonna just kill this for a second while
I'm explaining this and we'll do it for a second. Apparently,
if I waited just a little bit longer, a full video would have
come out that we could have just gone through, but now I have
to do more work. Apparently, that was 8 am on Thursday morning.
Oh, Thursday morning. It was 8:00 a.m. on Thursday morning. That
was the If you got in past 8 a.m. on Thursday morning after the
stuff dropped on Wednesday night, you were a sweeper. So, we're
already getting the brooms out. We're sweeping hard. If you didn't
get in in the first like 15 hours, you
>> That's Kathy. I don't think that's Kathy. Maybe. Maybe
it's Kathy. >> That's like crazy. It's Jover. But >> I
don't think so. Let me check. If he's got the VIP badge, it's
not Kathy. That's the person. And I I'm pretty sure that's the
name that was here before. Give me a second. I'll check. >> You're
going to get right.
>> You get right.
>> just giving you my honest. I'm like crazy compromised
on this topic. I have absolutely no problem saying it. I'm
>> Yeah, you came into chat just now. Did you not hear
me read the message or I talked about the message? >> I
didn't really know what you were what you were doing to be honest.
I was I was back and forth.
was uh uh gummy verse. Thank you for the gifted sub to Nick.
Are you guys looking for tips on how to find to find how to attract
viewers to your show? That was the message he sent. >> Dude,
debate purple. >> I do like the
>> I do like the um
that's very destiny coded. Very interesting.
come through a comment.
>> He does. That is what Stevie does. That is what Stevie
does. He comes into chat like that. >> Very unfortunate.
Very unfortunate. >> I do not want my friend to come out
of this looking like a domestic abusing.
I'm more compromised than I was when I made this stream. And
it's not because I know that she's a lying piece of It's not
that I know her friend's a lying piece of It's that while they
were lying, while they were doing this, while this was happening,
okay,
thank you for doxing me, Tom. While all of this was going on,
while I'm getting people on Twitter saying that I've stabbed
Tom in the back when Tom's totally on my side with us, or I'm
getting people from this community coming and telling me that
I've been sweeping for my night friend or something. All while
that's happening, this psychotic wretched
is trying to dox people in my personal life because I know him.
>> I Yeah, I don't see that. >> He's literally incapable
of insulting women without sounding like a total is so funny.
[laughter]
Why? Whack.
wait. I I will say
at least for me, I don't know about you, Queen. I said he responded
in a perfectly reasonable amount of time, and it didn't seem
like his coverage was sweeping to me. He basically covered it.
I didn't need him to like come out. I actually I think the only
comment I had was, "Oh, weren't you guys friends for like 10
years? If this guy's got like a fetish in his personal life that
he's never like made public in any way, you're going to cut him
off for that? That seems really excessive to me." That was That
was all I said about it. I don't know. Did you have a Do you
think he was sweeping?
>> Yeah. No, I said I said Nick's coverage was too boring
to watch cuz he wasn't
>> Oh, okay. Well, I I don't know. I just I guess is it
the the pre- sweep allegations from Chud saying like, "Don't
sweep this guys. You got to cover >> Yeah, he's he is just
lashing out Chard, but obviously he's an avoidant estrogenic
person, so he's not going to sit there and just talk at length
about his issues with Chard or make an argument. He'll never
go on stream with Chard. Well, he might. Apparently, he talks
apparently he talks a little bit more about it at some point.
>> I don't I don't believe
I believe every second. >> Yeah, I'm not even kidding you.
There was a manhunt for a person I attended VidCon with just
because I'm friends with Tom.
Yeah. No, I'm ser this has been deranged. This is absolutely
ridiculous. Turkey Tom's ex attempted to dox an offline person
that I
>> again I I that's an insane that's insane hyperbole right
[laughter] there. That's
pretty absurd hyperbole. I
think this sucks.
This sucks because I think
I think he probably discussed this with people
and it probably should have been pointed out like, "Hey, I I
don't know if I could go that quite that far." It's
I do feel like this is being spoken about this way to make it
make sense that this person got docked too. That is the impression
I get from this.
>> Attended VidCon with in 2025.
This was done because quote unquote she must have known something
and she wanted us to suffer for simply
>> you cannot. >> Wait, is he still there's he still
typing in chat? There's no way
situation. is still typing chat. Bro,
>> get on the stream. Get on the stream, you fat.
>> Is this for me? I'll I'll, by the way, I'll totally
drop I'll drop back the moderating like I did with Auggie and
Queen earlier. I don't have to I don't have to take a side on
this. I just want the content.
We all just want to have the conversation.
>> Yeah, just go and lay out your argument. I understand,
Nick. It's difficult for you. We get it.
We get it. making making any kind of coherent point is difficult
for the American Italian mind. The [__] mind, the
guinea mind struggles you I mean I don't want fentes slander
on the stream if you could just chill a little bit. It's really
rude actually.
We we literally will get you in here, Nick. It's totally fine.
It's totally fine. We're good. Augie, you're also muted, by the
way. I don't know if that's intentional or not. Just letting
you know. >> That's intentional. That's intentional. >> No,
listen. I got nothing to say. You guys are in a beef dig. I'm
not going to defend Nick or attack Nick. I'm just sitting here
in the >> You guys are making it weird. It's my friend.
I just Sorry. I I I understand. It's totally fine if you're not
saying anything. I just wasn't sure cuz you weren't responding
earlier either. I get it. No, I don't need you. Listen, I'm not
going to tell you. I'm not going to attack him either. >> Yeah,
I told you. I'm totally fine with
>> Okay. Okay. >> It's fine. That's fine. It's fine.
I know how you guys work. You guys,
>> I'm not I you just weren't comment on like the video
either. You wanted to watch it. So I was like,
>> well, you wanted to watch it with us, so I was like,
maybe he just muted for a second, but then Nick was in the chat,
so I get it. >> You're right. [laughter] >> Yeah,
I get it. Okay, okay. >> And then Nick came in the chat.
It's like you get caught with your pants down
>> Yeah, [laughter] yeah, yeah, sure, sure, sure, sure.
I get it. Yeah. >> Yeah, shut the up.
>> Yeah, he gets very sensitive about stuff like this.
I know you he doesn't like people hanging out with the wrong
about stuff behind the scenes as far as I'm understand.
>> Come on.
>> Well, that's true, isn't it? That's >> No, let's
keep playing. Let's listen.
>> This worthless gets no sympathy from me. She was telling
everybody I sh you not. She was telling everybody that she ran
to Kiwi Farms to protect women. Her her goal was to run to a
manpopulated forum, a doxing website, to smear my friend as
to save women.
Okay. I there are hints in in those directions. I'll give them
I'll give him that. I don't think she said those things were
categorical
or I don't think she said most of those things categorically,
but All right. I I don't know why you can't just say this is
like borderline harassing me reaching out to people in my personal
life trying to dig for information. That's like you can just
say that that's bad. That's condemnable. We can all say this
is crazy.
But the lie about doxing is obviously motivated. It's obviously
for a reason.
>> Yeah. And I by the wayh
how would you put this? like she wants to ask a question and
you could say that it's inappropriate for her to go ask this
question or something, but it seems like the information she
wants is not information to publish to hurt Nick or to expose
this person. It's literally like Tom cheated on me. I just want
to know who he cheated on me with. >> I think she'd publish
it. She'd obviously publish information she found. That's what
she'd been doing in the
>> No, she published she publish cheated >> but I
don't think she'd publish Nick's
>> No. Yeah. Yeah. I agree with you on that. Yes. I don't
think she'd probably if it's like a content creator that that
Tom's cheated with, she talk about that. >> She would say
who it is. >> She would reach she would reach out
to the person. Yeah. I don't there's no reason why we should
dog his girlfriend. I think if it was a content creator that
Tom cheated with almost definitely post it. I think otherwise
she's basically going to reach out. I I don't think as far as
I understand the other screenshots with testimony have names
blacked out. That's as far as I'm aware >> I'm just curious
like what like why do you think she would protect Dioro's
>> I just haven't seen any evidence that it's not about
whether she'd protect I haven't seen any evidence that she would
take the aggressive action of Docs and Dora's girlfriend in the
screenshots.
>> Understand it. So, she's only going after people that
relate to Tom. >> She's all she's been publishing is information
about Tom. And if someone has said they're okay with the name
being there, their name's there. But as far as I know, she hasn't
just outed people's names or anything like that. As far as I'm
aware. Okay. So, >> um that I mean that's basically what
I'm saying is I I've not seen an indication that she doesn't
understand doxing. She's been online a lot. So, I feel like she
understands the difference between publishing personal messages
you have and doxing somebody directly.
>> On timer, I think you guys are plenty good on the timer,
just so you know. >> Yo, pull this up. I just DMD this
>> being sent this. Okay. >> I just got sent this.
>> Let's see here.
Okay. When is this from? Thursday 11. Is
Is this new? This might be a new message she's throwing out here.
I'm not totally >> I don't think this is new. This is old.
>> This th
right Jesus. I'm I'm I'm struggling with days right now. >> Okay.
While I'm not going to hit the gas and the blood lust here, I
think it's very fair to make clear, by giving us this girl's
name, you'll likely destroy any goodwill Nick has for Tom and
by extension anyone loyal to Nick and significant impact significantly
impact fat boy. Do this only if you're certain. Personally, I'll
find it funny as hell. Turkey Tom does not redeem apparently.
I don't know if you've noticed, but I've been going gorilla mode
on Tom since I've got hard since I got hard proof he was cheating
on me and his friends were clearly all complicit in his degenerate
freak behaviors. So, at this point, I don't really care. Sorry,
Josh. I know you're probably mad at me. >> Oh, yeah. I
can see how you implication to to dogs more so more strongly
than the ones you posted before >> by giving us this girl's
name. So, hold on. Who is this girl in this case? That is I'm
not totally sure who the object of this post is girl. >> If
it is Nick's girlfriend, if it's Well, I need this guy. Can we
go back? >> This post, I will say this po this guy that
she's responding to, this is somebody that like viciously hates
me and Nick on the thread and has been trying to get her to attack
me and Nick consistently throughout the entire situation. So
>> yeah, who is this? Who is he? Who is she threat? I just
need to know the object. >> I would assume Dioro's girlfriend,
but I >> well, so there's one person that we said she'd
say. >> I suppose we could go to the >> the person
she cheated with.
>> And then >> let me pull up the original link
>> because if it would destroy any goodwill Nick has for
Tom, I would say
this person's in any case. I don't see how they could make this
calculation if it was Nick's girlfriend getting doxed. To be
fair, when I started covering this, I asked for all of the information.
I'm like, "Okay, just show me any evidence that she's um like
shown any proclivity for this." And we went through the other
two posts which don't show any proclivity for this.
So, hold on. Let me go trying to find specifically the other
post. I haven't seen this post on Twitter. So, this is like uh
I remember seeing this when I was reading a thread live, but
I haven't seen this posted today. So, this actually uh
reminded me of some But yeah, no, she definitely was. I feel
like she was she would have posted. I think she was angry. She
was angry at me definitely cuz she was lying about me. >> Definitely
angry at Nick. >> And her justification for being angry
at us was that Tom cheated on her allegedly at VidCon. And according
to her, we knew about it, so we deserve to get
basically, right? Sure.
Here. Hold on. I'll I'll try to go back in the thread and find
it if I can't get someone to send it to me. I'm looking to try
to find. And by the way, just be clear, I didn't know about her
getting cheated on. I also didn't really know anything about
her in particular. Tom told me he was dating some girl from Tinder
that he had met like two months ago. He told me that, "Oh, I'm
Yeah, I He was talking about some girl." And I was like, "Are
you dating somebody?" He's like, "Yeah, I've been dating some
girl whatever for 5 months." And I'm like, "Oh, okay." I didn't
know her name. I didn't know her face. I didn't know anything
about her. >> Is that
okay? I got Well, Bo leaked that there was a girlfriend maybe,
but >> hold on. We're going back in the thread.
Hold on. Uh for
>> he says page
thread moving.
>> Page 378. Ah
Okay, we've got Sacramento right here.
Got Gatorades right here. going up.
Uh, I think the Anon VidCon girl that Sacramento was talking
to would actually know who Nick Dioro's girlfriend is. Yeah,
I don't know who it is. She does. She told me that girl was apparently
long-term girlfriend. She's known since elementary school. Go
back up.
Oh, I don't want to free school the thread, so I'm just I'm reading
along here. Give me a second. Uh, yeah, hold on. I' I'm looking
at the post. Give me a second before I pull it up on stream because
I just don't I I don't know what information's in the thread.
And if I pull the thread up, like the thread name has information
at sub. Just give me a second. Right. Nick knew Tom was cheating
on me and going after girls in Destiny's orbit in the big 2025
after Destiny was already exposed to this was covering for him
so hard. Who else know who else what he knows? Nick, it's over
for your friends. You're a freak and everybody knows it. Why
the you covering for him? And then this Gatorade's response,
not sure just how strong you feel right now, but if you'd ever
truly like to burn the Tom Nick Doryo friendship and finally
allow Nick to feel some true consequences for his, there's a
very simple way to do that. Tell us who Nick Doryo's girlfriend
is. >> And then I do think now, so that gives us the >> I
told you guys about that post like an hour ago.
>> Um, you didn't link it though. >> I I don't feel
like you told me about this post. You you brought posts to me.
>> I definitely mentioned
Fair enough to me. She
That sounds like absolutely. She was saying she was going to
talk to your girlfriend. Yeah, fair >> Yes. I You maybe
I said something different. I'm usually just like, "Oh, can you
show me that?"
>> I feel like >> I didn't link it, but I just mentioned
that she had said that. I I I mentioned she had said that. I
didn't link it. Just to be clear.
>> Yeah. When you were in the chat, I was like looking
at those messages and I'm like, "That's not what she's saying
here, so I I need to see that." >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Fair
enough. >> That play.
Yeah, it does seem like she was um soliciting docs. Absolutely.
Uh she's also I don't know who would ever give her like these
names given >> soliciting docs. Soliciting docs is like
asking for the name, but she was saying she was saying I'm going
to docks. She's saying, you know, >> I'm going soliciting
docs from the um from the anonymous VidCon girl, right? >> Sure.
Sure. But I think that's already assumed, right? That's already
We already thought that she was trying to get the name for herself.
>> Well, it only becomes Docs if she's willing to publish
it. >> Yeah. So, we thought she was trying to get the name
of the girl that Tom cheated on her with, not necessarily Dioro's
girlfriend, right? >> Well, she is also doing that. She
is also doing that. >> See, what's the motivating factor
there to get Nick Dioro's Why is Nick Dioro's girlfriend's name
important in this whole situation? If she's cheated on and she's
angry, >> what is Nick? >> Obviously, it's the same
It's the same motivation as everything else. It's to try and
ruin Tom's life. I mean, I think we already established that
much. >> Yeah. No, she's uh totally psychotic. >> Well,
it's not even Tom's life. like what she's leaked. >> It's
not even ruining Nick's life, but it's just like a massive inconvenience
to Nick's life and also some random >> Yeah, it's trying
to [__] with Tom's personal relationships. That's
the ultimate goal, right? Is
>> I'm reading I'm trying to read through this whole thing
right now so I can see more. Give me a second. Should I put the
Nick thing back on for a second while we cover this? Cuz I want
to I do want to read through this thread and see if I can catch
up and see how people are responding to this overall.
>> Yeah, sure. Oh, Jesus Christ. We agree with him now.
So, I mean, is there any point in watching the stream through?
We agree with him at the dogs. Um, >> yeah. Well, I want
to watch him. No, no, no. I want to watch him. It's not That
wasn't even why I was watching the stream. I wanted to watch
him see the boat Chud Logic. That's what I was watching the stream
for. That's what I want to see. That's what I'm talking I believe
that's like a 20 second clip as far as I'm aware. >> I
think Lumpy Willy on Twitter. >> Yeah, it's like literally
a lumpy Willy clip. So, you >> Oh, hold on. Yeah. Did we
read this? I could have sworn we read this post, did we not?
>> I showed you guys a couple of these, but there's a couple
more in here. >> Yeah, he he's missing the actual
That's a problem. He's missing the actual one where the back
and forth happens about actually doing the docks. I knew I I
read this earlier today where he's responding to Conspiracy Lemur
about this. He's missing the actual post that shows that this
is happening.
>> Yeah, I read the Listen, I It's fine. I I just I looked
at this and I'm like based on this I have like I have no information
that leads me to believe she was good at docs
except somebody referencing it and then I tried to look at that
and what they were referencing and I still don't see it but I
need to go back further apparently.
Um none of none of the post do used to defend himself were this.
This is just him them going back and finding stuff retroactively.
Well, I think >> No, I'm sure they saw it. I'm trying.
>> So I I could see Yeah. What I could see happening is
he probably saw the post. He knew it happened and then he went
and found posts adjacent and sometimes you don't have a perfect
theory of mind where like you know what people don't know and
know what you know that's different, right? So he probably included
that knowledge of that previous post while he was posting this.
Forgot that like you needed that for context.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Exactly.
Different kind of mistake.
Check 7576 on the thread. Well, that's probably the one I did
read that I did actually go back and read. Hold on.
Yeah, that's probably the one that I did read judging by the
That's the one that should be here. I'll I'll actually grab it
real quick and do a screenshot for people so they can see it
on the stream.
Oh, no. That's not the one.
That's not the one. Um, the one that shows who the object of
all of this is is back further in the thread,
but it's fine. Okay,
go to the lumpy willy clip real quick. This one is not the one
I'm looking for.
Jesus. Lumpy Willy clip in a lot of this right now. Which one
of these is
Mr. Chud? Okay, right here. Perfect. >> AM her time. >> The
problem that I have with Chud is that he went public and he started
complaining like, I'm talking about sensitive society. I'm talking
about a cheeto. It's like, nah, nah, you're [__]
talking about me.
>> Wait, didn't he say that after I maybe I'm crazy. Didn't
he say that after Nick covered it that he's like talking about
other people? This is the second clip.
Wait, there's another one. Or is it just this one right here?
Oh, there's two. Yeah. Okay, we should watch this one first.
>> I feel bad for Chud. >> The goat. Thank you for
the phone. >> I feel bad for Chud now. He's taking I don't
feel bad for Chud. Chud went live. This thing came out at like
[__] what was like between 6:00 and 10:00 the night
before and he was up by 8:00 a.m. saying the great sweep is on
and sicked his entire [__] audience on me. I don't
feel bad for Chud. Not one bit. >> See, this is the gay.
I totally I totally agree with his point that Chud like went
way too hard way too early and it was like totally It's just
so revealing though when you see it's like sick this whole audience
on me. It's so revealing. It's like he tries to act so above
it all, but it's literally like a couple of on Twitter say, "Oh,
you're sweeping. You're like a fat." It's It's the worst thing
that's happened to all. >> I Yeah, I'm just not a I think
Chud was like pre he was making a pre-algigation or something.
He's He's obviously saying I expect like it's one of those things
where it's like you want people to cover it. So you you'll basically
say I sure hope they do. I sure hope they're not going to run
away. It's not the same as saying like um you are sweeping this.
you have you are going to >> when you're first the story
like you get that you know home ground advantage you can just
kind of flex your and just be like yeah will anyone else touch
this or whatever. I mean me and Chud argued about this on his
show and also
in uh the group chat
but it was very it was a fun conversation. I don't know. I do
think he was like way too like early with it. Like literally
within hours he was like they're sweeping and it's like okay
who's sweeping? Well, I sorry I've said it again. That's not
it's not they're sweeping. It's like I sure hope they don't sweep
this. I sure hope the sweep's not going to come in. Right. I
think that was I think that's a different thing. Unless he directly
said they're sweeping by not covering this. I I just don't think
>> like the presumption that nobody was going to cover
this.
>> Yeah. I just think even the presumption that nobody
was going to cover this is like crazy cuz it's like
>> I don't know big allegations against one of the biggest
commentary YouTubers.
>> Yeah. That's because historically people have not covered
>> Yeah. Yeah. And that's why, you know, if you throw out
that kind of rage bait, like obviously people are going to, you
respond to it, right? >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But it's it's
just like a different thing. Jesus here. This is apparently the
longer clip. Let's check this out. >> I feel bad for the
longer Chug clip right here. >> Thank you for the follow.
>> I feel bad for Chud now. He's taking I don't feel bad
for Chud. Chud went live. This thing came out at like what was
like between 6:00 and 10:00 the night before and he was up by
8:00 a.m. saying the great sweep is on and sicked his >> Is
anyone else psyched that like >> [__] a feel
bad for Chud. Not one bit >> on February. >> The
Great Sweep is on at 8:00 in the morning. Well, guess what? If
you don't go fly back to whatever bonger country you're in, if
you're not streaming by 8 a.m. tomorrow morning, I'm thinking
you're sweeping this up. >> Holy [__] [laughter]
for whatever bonger country you're in.
The the bonger country the one. Okay. All right. >> Okay.
[laughter] >> Kind of person you are. >> She says
she wishes
>> I'm baffled. Just carry on. >> Maybe if I stopped
covering Ethan Klein one day and people stop messaging him in
his chat where he's like >> see it's like this such funny
cove and it's like no one's complaining about you covering. That's
not the complaint. You know that's not a complaint.
So crazy.
How is this? Explain to me how it's any different to what you
guys used to cry about Hassan for. Ogie, explain that one to
me.
>> What? He's talking [__] about you guys.
>> It's not talking. It's It's the same. I'm going to just
make up a criticism that no one's saying and cry about it. >> Don't
people call him like the Ethan Klein waiting room?
>> No one People might call him Ethan Klein waiting room,
but no one's criticizing him for covering Ethan Klein a lot.
They're criticizing him for being biased, right? They're criticizing
him for lying, for being wrong, for being
>> And that's the same that someone like, you know, whoever
you're criticizing. Doesn't have to be Hassan. >> That's
a very lovely example for some >> Hold on. Can I do a quick
Hassan example? Um, you know, people act like I'm evil because
I just want universal healthcare. I'm People act like I'm evil
because I just want universal healthcare. Guys, I don't understand.
Is it really? I just don't want Palestinians. Then people act
like I'm evil. That's uh that's like the thing I'm witnessing
here. All right. Well,
>> It's just like Israel, bro.
Nicholas has to get on this stream because unfortunately now
we're in an awkward situation where
>> Yeah. Og's avatar of Nick. Oie. Oie. Make the Nick argument.
>> Defend him. >> Yeah. No. Defend him. Make the
Nick >> He can defend himself. He's a grown ass >> No.
No. No. No. But he literally can't. He literally can't >> defeat
[laughter] himself. Yeah, >> you know, he he clearly he
clearly knows about himself that he's not capable of defending
himself in the conversation. So, you need to be here. You need
to >> put up a fight. Give us something to >> Listen.
All right. Listen, you know, amidst all the glazing accusations,
just admit Nick is bigger than you guys. I know he's just in
your chat, but he's bigger than you guys. [laughter] He's
>> together actually sit there crying.
They're crying in his discord. level yourselves up and then one
day you can meet him at his >> Do you think Do you think
if I had 5,000 viewers right now, Nick would hop on the stream?
You think that's the actual
>> Um, probably not. I don't know. >> I feel like
if I feel like if a streamer with 5,000 followers call him out.
>> Do you think Nick would debate his son?
>> I think he would actually. [laughter]
>> Even though Willie
is >> cuz Willie did. He's got to avenge Willie. Apparently
Willie got
>> That's not I don't think that's a reason why Nick would
do it.
>> I mean, why wouldn't you debate? If Assan hit you up
right now for a debate, obviously you're going to [__]
take that [__] right? >> No, I don't think
you would do it. I think you do. I think there a chance. >> You
don't think he would? >> Makes sense to buy his public
image.
>> I mean, just for like I don't know. I feel like >> if
Assan hit me up, I'm not a debater. If Assan hit me up tomorrow
was like, "Let's debate on stream." I'm doing it. It's for the
publicity. You're you're like not as sensitive about like exactly
what people >> Well, I do it purely for selfish reasons.
I do it for the money and publicity. I'd be like, why would I
turn this down? >> Some people some people motivated more
by other things, you know, in certain ways. You won't you won't
instantly see a bunch of money just from arguing with, you know,
it's not like that simple. And on the way there, it's a it's
a >> I just feel like a stupid opportunity to turn down.
Like if people were talking about you being mean to you, saying
you're like a cryptofascist, saying all these horrible things
about you stick in your head for years.
>> I think he would debate Hassan to be honest with you.
I think you just stick to the exact same talking points he's
used for months. >> Well, there's plenty of talking to
use against him. Like
in the dialogue tree.
>> You think you think so? Okay. So, what's the first uh
Okay, let's let's uh let's uh role play it then. What's the first
point? You can't you can't debate a Hassan. Hassan is not as
as good as as you at it. Okay. I'm telling you, Nick just runs
the dialogue tree.
>> I'll train you on. I'll train I'll train you on. I'll
train your weights on. I'll try and dumb myself down from it.
Okay. >> No, no, no. But hold on. Here's the other thing
is Nick's just going to like >> Well, you would go after
him for the anti
be like, "You lied about this. You okay? So, how was your
anti-semitic? How was Go for the first one. What was that?
Well, I don't have any issue with him being anti-Semitic, so
it's not my argument. But I mean, I would just say like I mean
whatever
whatever that was in the movie. He lied about like the ship that
got captured by the >> If we want to Yeah. If we want to
if we want to [laughter] just do a proxy debate, I'm going to
go, okay, you totally celebrated and thought it was awesome when
they captured those civilians when they kidnapped. >> I
don't have the Hassan talking points memor. I don't like Assan,
but I don't have like the anti-Asan talking points memorized.
But I'm sure like if you were to debate Hassan, it's like even
if you were like a complete I think a Cheeto could debate Hassan.
Like he would just have the talking points. >> Cheeto would
get [laughter] smarter than I'm not saying he would do well,
but I'm just saying like >> it would be a conversation
you could accept because you would have the script in front of
you. I'm not saying he would do well. I'm just saying like, you
know.
>> No, I think it'd be No, I don't think it's as easy as
you think it is, man. I really don't think it's as easy as you
think it is. Are you going to do >> people are in such
an echo chamber with >> Hold on. Hold on. Yeah. Here. Uh,
you celebrated and you totally put on your stream and celebrated
those people getting kidnapped. Those civilians. You're Hassan.
Go.
>> No, I didn't. >> Galaxy Leader.
>> Yeah, you did. You totally. You said it was awesome.
>> I was just I was a journalist. I was just covering journalistic
journalistic >> Nope. You were totally psyched about it.
You said it was awesome. You and Nick were both Oh my god, this
is like Rust. It's so cool. Right. You're >> Oh, yeah.
He said he said there is 10 towns down 10 toes down supporting
it. >> Also, yes. 10 toes down supporting the
>> Trust me, there's like >> Yeah. Yeah. Wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Let me let me think through. Let
me think. Let me think through. Let me think through. What would
he be thinking? What would he be thinking? Um,
>> he celebrated it. He would say, "Yeah, I celebrated
it. What's wrong with him forcing a blockade against state?"
>> Oh, this is going to They're not going to be able We've
had this debate and there's going to be >> Yeah, exactly.
That's where they lose. That's where they lose every time. That's
where cuz it instantly goes into >> That's where they lose.
But I can't I
already We've had this argument before. So I already have a different
argument, but I don't think they're going to I don't know if
he's going to say it.
>> The answer is there's not a genocide. Nick has to be
willing to argue the genocide, which means know how to argue
the genocide.
>> Yeah. Well, that is it. That is it cuz you know I mean
skits are posting a little bit, but it is all downstream from
certain political streamers. Um,
>> So, their position, their true position, their true
position is there is no genocide. Nick's true position is there
is no genocide. Ethan's true position is there is no genocide.
They won't say that. They won't argue that. They can't argue
that. They don't know how to argue that. They haven't thought
it through enough, but it is all downstream from certain political
streamers. >> Says there's no genocide.
>> No, he doesn't say that. But that is ultimately when
push comes to shove, that's where he sits and that's where his
prescriptions are because um >> in order to call Hassan
a terrorist for the Houthi support, you basically do have to
um >> argue there's no genocide. >> No, there's no
argue he's a terrorist, but it's good to condemn him for supporting
it. >> You have to basically be arguing there's no genocide.
I see
Assan did open it up with the capturing the civilians part, but
the rest of everything like the if he if he could get it back
to Hezbollah, then you could support Hezbollah as him if you
think there's a genocide going on and like sort of have some
support there. >> Yeah. Um >> like people the immediate
analog everyone's going to draw is just like Nancy Germany. It's
like is it okay to enforce a blockade against like a you know
Germany if that was the case and then no one's going to bite
the bullet where they say oh no actually non-state actors can
never do a blockade even if there's a the most heinous genocide
ever going on and then or or someone's going to say well that
was so bad it's okay where do you draw the line on genocide what
genocide is bad enough to where you can enforce a blockade as
a non-state actor and they would yeah they would just uh any
commentary you >> Assad knows to have that argument I don't
know if Assad have that argument. >> I think he does. I
think he does.
>> I don't think so.
>> He just said, "I stand 10 toes with the Houthies." That's
all. >> Yeah, he did. And then and then he I think he basically
pushed that down that
>> Did he? Okay. All right. >> Ron Pride, thank you
for the 10 gift, dude. Let's go.
>> Huge 10 gifties. We're having a proxy. This is where
content's gotten to. We can't have a conversation with Hassan.
We can't have a conversation with Nick. So, we just roleplay
Hassan and Nick and have the conversation ourselves. Let's >> Meanwhile,
Meanwhile, Orgie frantically replies to DMs of Nick going, "Oh,
yeah." I'm n I'm ning every all these guys from my social. [laughter]
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I'm still talking to Nick right now.
Implying I was talking to him earlier. >> You get some
updated talking points from Nick. Can Nick is Nick through you?
>> You really want to get him on here? I don't think that's
going to happen. I'm just going to put a a bet. >> Well,
I don't think he's going to come on here, but I'm >> I'm
just looking to keep conversation going. Okay. >> Yeah.
We we want the Why are Why are you against the idea of like,
you know, being just trying to stalem the argument, giving us
like, you know, what do you what do you think's going on? What
do you think's You know, what would be the defense?
>> The defense. >> Surely you're of any of the points
that we're bringing up that we were bringing up. Where were we
before?
>> I can't remember what was going on in the clip that
we were watching. I think something sprung off of that was
>> Yeah. Going after Chud.
Oh, I mean him and Chud have like a rivalry or whatever. I don't
really get involved in that. I like both them both. I like Chud.
I like Nick. I don't really see a reason to give a take on that.
I think uh they just have differences. I think you guys have
differences. >> You don't get you don't give Yeah, but
you don't give takes on like what you know the beef between them.
You don't think you could you could opine on it at >> Honestly,
I just don't really think about it. Like when I when people that
I like go after each other, I don't really even analyze what
they're bickering about. I only care about it when I get involved
if they're going after me. So,
I mean, Nick doesn't like Chud because Chud called him out. I
mean, I think I was very vocal on I I agreed with Nick on like
the uh sweeping stuff, but I debated Chud about it on his own
show. So, we've already >> That just feels like a very
convenient like uh and very unique mindset to have the idea that
when two friends are beefing, you don't analyze it.
I mean, I'll analyze it, but I don't really have like a solid
like, oh, he's right or he's wrong kind of view. I just kind
of like view it as just I see both sides. I understand what's
happening, and I don't really want to get involved.
>> I've actually not heard this directly before, but Nick
cut Chut off. Nick like decided he wasn't going to hang out with
Chut anymore because of that one comment about like the EHD.
>> People are saying both sides, Andy. It's not both sides.
It's neither side. I don't really just I just think it's stupid
to just constantly get yourself involved in things that don't
matter to you, you know? >> I I suppose I don't understand
what the
>> I I think it's
I don't know. I'm not sure just But I feel like it's like um
you don't have to get your yourself involved. Just like speak
about it,
>> Yeah. I just don't really care about what they're arguing
about though. Like I think it's stupid.
>> I I told Chud directly in DMs. I was like, I would rather
us all just get along, just make content together. Like, I don't
really care about whatever they disagree on.
Yeah, wouldn't that that would be so much better. I just don't
understand why we can't do that.
I'm I'm totally on the same page as you. Okay. What has to be
fixed? What do you think has to be fixed, Auggie, for that to
happen? >> We just all on the same page.
>> Dioro, somebody has as somebody that's known Dioro for
so long, like he does not mix with you guys. like there is something
going on. I can't really verbalize it, but there's something
he came in here every week for like 6 months. Once a week he
come around to >> I was never around when he was >> He
was in the oil course late night. He was like hanging out late
night. He was leaking stuff around all the time.
>> I was never around when you guys are friendly. I only
have known you guys as enemies. So,
[laughter] >> he showed me all of his favorite like old
commentary dramas.
>> Yeah. Yeah, we got along perfectly. And then I I think
I literally just said, "Hey, uh I think you by the way, total
mistake on my part cuz this person is a terrible human being,
but I think I said, "Hey, you're going after Natsu Erdite right
now for a thing that you could easily be accused of. I think
you should just chill." I said that on Twitter and that like
totally obliterated any friendship we could have had apparently.
>> Okay, everyone's >> going I don't want to get
into like the going back and getting all this uh the old stuff.
I feel like it's just like um
the issue right now is like
Nick is
very sensitive to Chud making call outs to him. He Chud made
a comment about Nick and Nick the [__] out.
>> yeah, Chud's called me out multiple times. I mean, I
just respond by I like Chud called me out in the past. I would
make fun of him. Chud called me out recently. I went on stream
to debate him. I have a very different approach when it comes
to conflict than Nick. You know, I like to just talk about it
openly and and discuss it. Uh he likes to distance himself from
it. I don't really see like a problem with his approach. I think
that honestly >> Well, is the problem with his approach
not that it's antithetical to everyone doing their jobs?
>> What do you mean? Well, if Nick's doing something and
calling him out ends the friendship, you can't call Nick out,
but you can call everyone else out. >> I call Nick out,
>> although I mostly do it privately to be fair, but I
I disagree with Nick plenty of times. I don't really uh
>> I've called him out publicly, though. I mean, we had
that argument like a year ago about the um ironically about you
guys about the whole Jtock Willie Mack argument. And do you seem
a little bit sensitive about that? Was that not a little bit?
>> I mean, he argued with me. Honestly, he didn't seem
any more sensitive than my usual arguments go with my friends.
I mean, I argue with my friends all the time, so but he didn't
cut me off. He didn't make weird snide comments about me afterwards.
>> Um, so I mean,
>> generally Nick is a guy that I agree with on a lot of
things. So, we don't really have much conflict anyway. But when
we do have conflict, I haven't really I mean, we've had fights
and stuff in the past, of course. I mean, the I think people
know like the most famous argument me and Nick got into was about
like a >> Okay. Okay. Okay. Well, I suppose I suppose let's
bring this back because what we were saying a moment ago is you
were saying, "Well, we why can't we just get along and be friends
and make content together?" Well, because >> Yeah, I think
make content with you can't make content with Nick. That's the
>> That's That is the problem, right? Nick is the problem
there. >> Yeah, you guys want to make content with
>> Well, no, we all were making content. He was perfectly
happy to make content. We were all happy making content until
he was on the receiving end of anything from us, right? Whether
it was Jstalk, me, Chud,
>> what was the argument that separated him from you guys?
Was it Willie Mack? >> So, with JSTalk, it was the Willie
Mac and Aerodite stuff.
>> With me, it was um H3 stuff.
And with Chud, obviously it's H3 stuff.
>> I [clears throat] feel like with Chud was more like
Turkey Tom stuff. There was like beef before that, but like recently
it's been like the Turkey Tom >> Oh, come on. He was actually
cut off when the EHD call out happened and Nick just does this
thing where he pretends to be cool with someone and keep >> Were
they cut off or were they just not talking to each other for
a while?
>> Uh uh they were talking to each other in DMs, but it
was just no more collabs on stream, right? like no more. >> As
somebody that knows Nick, I have not known him. I don't want
to get into personal conversations, but I [clears throat] have
not known him as somebody that speak that spoke ill of Chud or
like cut him off up until obviously recently with the Tom stuff,
but like before that, you know, I mean, there was obviously some
tension in the air, but it wasn't like cut off level, you know,
tension.
>> Well, I thought the thing was was that he was not going
to go on his stream anymore after May after that first H3 cut
off call out. And that's he don't go on my streams anymore.
>> Stop giving these cop answers. Stop giving the cop answers.
>> You don't even stream anymore. What are you talking
about? Who are you talking >> No, he does not get on my
streams.
>> But I don't care about that. >> Oh, like he has
a rule not to go on your >> No, he does not want to go
on my streams. I think he said that publicly.
>> I don't care. You're You don't have to go on my streams
to be my friend. Like that's not how I operate. >> Okay,
we weren't talking about like being friends. doing the whole
thing was about making content together, right? >> Yeah.
Well, I'm talking about making someone content with me. That's
what I'm saying. Now, he'll have me on his streams, I think.
>> Well, yeah. Yeah. Okay. But the whole Okay, wait. Wait.
But let me follow back. The whole conversation we we were initially.
You said, "Why can't we all get along and make content? We can't."
I said, "We can't make content cuz Nick's a [__]
problem." And now you're just It's like you're just saying, "Yeah,
Nick's a [__] problem. He doesn't want content with
anyone." >> Yeah. Um,
I just what I'm trying to explain is that
him >> what you're trying to do is do anything other than
point to Nick. That's what you're trying to do [laughter] on
me. >> Come on. You guys are forcing >> Be real.
Be real. You that is >> talk about how he's a [__]
or something like that.
[laughter] No, I understand.
I understand why he doesn't engage with all of these >> in
what he would view as pointless convers. I mean, honestly, these
are pointless conversations. I'm not benefiting myself. Look,
look, let me be clear. I'm not benefiting myself by calling into
this stream. I'm just doing it for fun, >> right? Like,
>> if anything, I'm benefiting JTO, but I'm
>> but I'm just doing it right now because I'm legitimately
enjoying this conversation, right? Like I I think Nick is in
like more of a businessminded mode where he is like working on
growing his channel, his his >> his stuff or whatever,
right? And he doesn't need to be tied down by like forcing himself
to argue. Do you need to debate every single point? I know you
guys do, right? But I argue with Aiden all the time about this.
Sometimes
>> Can I just give you a perfect example of why Nick knew
he had that knowledge that that post on Kiwi Farms existed, right?
He was in here instantly when he had a fight. He knew he could
win instantly in here. I think that says all you need to know
about the conversations he won't have that he'll refuse to have,
right?
>> I mean, it's smart, right? Only have
You could say it's smart, but it's like it's just describing,
right? >> Conflict avoidant. That is what you're saying.
[laughter] He's a conflict
>> I mean, I think he has different perspectives. I think
he has different goals. He has different things. >> Stop.
This is literally the most
It sounds like Becca. It sounds like >> It's not Hold on.
Hold on. Hold on. It's not even dishonest, though. It's not dishonest.
It's It's literally just saying that Nick knows he's wrong, so
he's not going to go talk about this. And that's all. benefit
yourself from having conversations that you risk, you know, damaging
your brand by. Like right now, this whole conversation we've
been having where I was talking to docs and stuff and even now
I look bad. I don't care at the end of the day. It doesn't really
look bad.
>> Well, I think obviously I sound bad. If you're willing
to come in and be like >> I think most people in the chat
think that I sound weak right now, but I don't care about that
because I'm just trying to have like a legitimate conversation
with people. I think if you're Nick, if you're somebody I the
thing is I can have these conversations with you guys where I
can risk looking bad because I'm not trying to build a career
in this sort of niche. I'm not trying to elevate my channel.
If I was trying to elevate my channel, if I was really trying
to like turn myself go on a generational run, maybe I would be
more avoidant of conversations where potentially I'm not prepared
to handle certain things that I'm not ready to talk about. Right.
>> Okay. Yeah. This is just like describing how everyone
becomes like a grifter basically, right? [laughter] It's just
like you you a avoid criticism. Yeah. Wow. Great strategy, bro.
>> I mean, it's smart, right?
>> Yeah. Lying them to make money is >> I'm not saying
about lying. Lying is not good. But like avoiding situations
that you don't have to be in.
>> Why is that? What's the problem here?
>> Okay. The initial point. So
there's not a problem if you don't want to be on someone's stream.
You have to go on someone's stream. Again, initially where this
came from was you saying, "I wish we could all just get along
and make content together and why can't why can't we?" And you're
just not you willing to >> Nick is trying to build something
right now and you guys are trying to take them down. You're trying
to destroy them. >> I'm just No one was trying to destroy.
Yeah, but no one was trying to understand Nick is trying to build
something. That is the that is fundamentally what it says. Nick
feels like he's trying to build something and he feels like he
can't let >> you guys are like the ankle biters at the
bottom trying to bite at him and every time he speaks or whatever,
right? Why does he have to engage with you guys at every single
point? >> He doesn't have to engage us at every single
point. But if you if there's legitimate criticism of you, you
kind of have an obligation obligation to respond to it in some
way. Yeah.
>> And there is plenty of legitimate respond to criticism
>> to legitimate criticism. Yes. Can I explain the um the
original valid point against you? You should respond to >> Mhm.
Like I think my issue was, you know, I went on that stream with
Willie and I think I didn't express my my concerns like super
effectively, but I think they were broadly correct, most of them.
And I think the way I expressed them led Nick to like totally
go hard on me in a stream. And I was like, "Hey, I think um I
think I spoke poorly, but do you want to just talk about it?"
And he said yes. And then I think he realized that I did have
a point and that like Willy's video was quite bad and it missed
a lot of stuff that would have been very easy to figure out and
then he canceled that conversation and refused to talk to me.
He talked to you. You made the exact points I would have made
and he looked fairly foolish doing it and it's I feel like I
got totally over where he tried to paint me as like a complete
to his audience and then he refused to have any conversation
with me after. So that left like a bad taste in my mouth. So
I don't know. I feel like if he's gonna make those criticisms
and then when I say, "Hey, I think those are like not I think
some of the things you said that's not true. I could just explain
this, >> right?" I I think >> I think reasonably
that we were friends before that. We could have just had that
conversation. It seemed really weird that he totally dodged speaking
to me after that. >> After even after he said he would.
>> Yeah, that's a fair perspective. I mean, I don't you
know, I don't really know I I only knew of you by the time you
and Nick were enemies. I didn't even know you guys were like
friends. Like I knew he like came under stream. I didn't know
even know how long he came under streams or whatever. >> I
don't think of him as an enemy outside of the fact that he's
like supporting Willie Mac lying about me.
>> Outside of that, if he just was like, "Yeah, Willy Mack's
actually a lying loser." I'd be fine. I don't I don't need to
be enemies with Nick. I don't want to be enemies with Nick. >> But
it's like, why do I have to answer for Nick? I feel like every
time I come on here, as much as I like talking to you guys, it's
like I do have to answer for Nick. I have to be like you guys
are basically asking like why is he a why is he a drifter you
understand why that's a totally unfair point to make to me right
now right >> you understand why that's totally unfair that's
an insane thing to say because I was just covering Nick minding
my own business and you came into my chat and started arguing
for Nick >> okay well on that specific point but I mean
just in general we're chilling or whatever right and you guys
are like why is he a
>> the content I challenged you specifically on something
yeah I challenged challenged you on something specifically which
was about the doxing stuff like that because I opened that conversation,
right? And we had that conversation, but now later on you guys
are bringing it back up and just talking more generally just
about him as a person, right? And you guys are asking me to like
cycle analyze him. I'm going to do it to the best of my ability
because he's my friend. But it's like at the end of the day,
there's really nothing I can say that's satisfying to you guys
unless I were to just go scorched earth on him and just be like,
"He's a great >> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. So, okay.
So, so >> hold on. Just wait. I need to actually before
you go, I just got to say one >> One thing. Just separate
me and Quman. I said I'm fine with you not wanting to comment
on that or I think you already laid out his business strategy
that it is a business strategy. Okay. So, I'm separate me and
him. Quan, you go now and make your criticism.
>> No, you I lost it, dude.
>> You threw me off. >> How did you lose it? I told
you. Hold on for a second. >> You threw me off. That's
why I wasing, dude, cuz I just lost it as you were saying that.
I immediately lost it. Okay, hold on. Let me walk back. What
was Auggie saying here? Here, I can pull it up on stream. Augie
was just saying that I feel like you guys, you want me to totally
disavow Nick maximally, that he's a grifter, that he's a loser.
>> Yeah, sorry. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. You don't have to say that because you
might think the opposite and you could defend that point.
But if your reading of the evidence would lead you naturally
to that conclusion, if you were honest, then don't you think
that's a problem, Orie? >> But I don't think him not wanting
to talk to you guys is like a sign of weakness. I think it's
a sign of
>> But you can reframe any dishonesty as strategy, or it's
not about talking to me. It's about actually responding to the
criticism or at least even just change maybe or correcting things
he said or whatever. But he doesn't. He doesn't. It is still
just the strategy is clear. The strategy just be dishonest. That's
the strategy. Be dishonest for Ethan Klein. That's his >> If
he said wrong, I think he should correct that, right? I would
call him out if he said wrong. So,
>> sure. But okay. Well, I suppose
what has he said recently that >> it's about being completely
in contradiction to previous daily principles. that that's usually
what it is without explaining why those >> previously he
would hop on a stream >> because no no no no nothing to
do with the stream stuff I'm talking about act the actual criticisms
that predate any of the stream stuff um so
like for in the the whole big thing you know is the snark uh
like narrative that that Ethan runs right same as the literally
the same narrative as the antifan thing that that Destiny runs
which is the same thing in the Willy Mac video exactly same thing
that said in the Willy Mac video basically you It's it's all
the same narrative and that is obviously and you you obviously
know this totally in contradiction. Makes no sense with any of
the things that you guys would have defended years ago. And you
obviously know that you're totally on the train. Nick has not
reconciled how he supports every step of what Ethan Klein does
without uh just going, "Oh, well, yeah, it might be a problem
or it might be bad, but I just don't feel any sympathy for."
And that's what he does. Like that's what I keep seeing about.
That's what he does every time. That is not responding to criticism.
that is not uh changing behavior in accordance with a valid criticism.
Nick is dead to rights on that. He is literally nailed to the
wall. There is no rebuttal on that and he will never respond
to it adequately. He will never say, "Oh yeah, my principles
are just totally changed. I think all anonymous uh Reddit [__]
poster should be unmasked." He's never It's never going to happen.
>> Well, but that's fine. That that is it's good that you
call him out on that, right? Like why do I have to be involved
in this? Like
why do I have to do I do I have to call him out as a liar too?
Like for you guys to be satisfied? Like if you guys are making
streams calling him out wait with that. I don't think there's
anything wrong with >> Okay. So wait, hold up. So why do
you think you needed to cover the Tom stuff?
>> Because I felt like if I didn't cover a major allegation
that was against my friend, then that would look kind of suspicious
and bad. >> It's just the optics. It's just the optics.
Well, I just think you should give an opinion about that whole
situation. Your friends in the news or whatever, right? Like,
you know, just go over it. What's the harm in that?
>> What's the harm in giving your take on
how Nick's totally in contradiction with his previous state principles?
Like, >> cuz it's me. He's my friend. He's my friend. [laughter]
>> Exactly. So, because feelings >> Oh, man. >> Listen,
I'm not in the business of >> Is it Tom Fus again? Is that
what we're saying or is that the Is that the issue? Is [laughter]
that
>> Listen, I'm not in the business of looking for like
every little way that I can critique and nitpick my friends.
I'm sure there's like 10,000 things I could >> That's what
I'm saying. I'm not saying you have to be, but I, you know, personally,
me personally, me personally, I like to just be even. I like
to, if my friends doing something wrong, I like to say they're
doing something wrong. And if I would describe it in one way,
someone I don't know, I describe it the same way for them. If
my friends are pissing me off, then I like to do that. But like
in general, if you're my buddy, I'm not trying to make a fool
out of you. You know, >> if you're my buddy, I'm not trying
to >> You're not trying to make a No, I'm saying you're
not trying to. But if something is happening, why can you not
simply describe it as it is happening? They're doing something.
You see that you believe them to be doing something. You see,
>> I did that with Will. That's why Willie Mack hates me
now because I just I saw what he was saying about you guys and
just about dodging in general. You keep jumping to other examples,
>> but I understand I I'm certain you were nowhere near
as close with Willie Mack as you were with Nick. >> You,
Nick, and Tom are very tightnit compared to any of the other
groups you had. Bo Black is was pretty close, but you know, not
not as close as you three. And I'm sure Connor, you're very close
to, but the other two are maybe less close to. >> So, as
far as I understand, you guys are essentially, you know, inseparable.
So, you constantly going, "Oh, well, this lesser friend who I,
you know, I'm obviously you obviously don't value it in the same
way, right? So, it's to keep jumping to that. So, let's just
go >> the big issue. Something Nick's saying, I'll probably
go into him in private about it, right? I'll probably be like,
"Dude, I think you're totally off basis on here. I'm not necessarily
going to go at him on public because that could be perceived
as like I'm attacking his his or something like that, right?"
Which I understand to you guys that's a big thing to say or whatever,
right? But
I Nick's doing a thing. I'm doing a thing. We're tight. If he
really is saying something that bothers me or I feel is incorrect,
my go-to is not just to like ignore that, but I'm probably going
to go to just be like it's a prerequisite to be friends with
Nick that you don't criticize him publicly. >> Well, I've
criticized him publicly before, but like
>> I guess it depends on like what the type of criticism
is. If it's just he has like a take on some stupid drama, that's
one thing. or if I am criticizing the way that he runs his entire
stream, like saying that he's a who who won't hop on other people's
streams and stuff like that, that's a little bit more of like
almost like a character attack at that point, right? >> And
I don't want to do that against >> Yeah. But we're not
talking about the stream thing right now, right? We're talking
about uh >> I'm just using that as an example, >> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. But this is about drama coverage. This isn't about
just like some stupid personal thing.
>> What has he said recently that I should call him out
for? Um, what's the most recent example
Nick doing something absolutely evil Klein
I'd have to go back through my I think he was pretty disingenuous
in how he's painting the Chud stuff. I think even this where
he's like um sort of leading this whole thing of being like why
hasn't Chud responded to this? I genuinely regard I I feel like
you know you you you
do um Okay, so the lawsuits the or the DMCA's in fact the DMCA's
the DMCA and the lawsuits in fact Nick has uh constantly either
said he's withholding judgment or said I don't have any sympathy
for these people
or made slight mistruthful statements like saying um oh I think
a lot of this is from paid members content when it wasn't and
stuff like that to do with the fundamental copyright lawsuits
that are that started the whole thing >> between Ethan
Klein and
Denn the DMCA for snarkers of the Reddit. >> Yeah. Then
for the um for the full lawsuits as well those lawsuits
>> um being okay with say the Denim's lawsuit that would
be that would be seen as a total sin before. Right.
Would you agree with that?
>> Being okay with the con? Yeah, I think I'd agree with
that. >> Yeah. So,
do you not think it is Nick is operating
totally in contradiction
to previously stated principles by going along with >> Um,
well, I will say this. I mean, I that is something that I've
actually argued with Nick about in private over. >> Okay.
[laughter] Okay. >> I disagree with Nick completely on
the denim stuff. So um [laughter] >> to me to me right
that that is like a huge so so so here's so >> the denim's
lawsuit the H3 lawsuits all this huge story absolutely massive
story and Nick is the top H3 orbiter is the H3 >> desk
when I argued with him about it in the past I don't cover the
Ethan stuff I don't really even pay attention to it so I I wasn't
equipped enough to know it just seemed to me based on what he
But do you not think this is the sort of thing that is kind of
like, you know, maybe worth covering? Maybe worth covering like
how Nick's engaged with this because Nick is the essentially
H3 News Desk. He's the commentary channel that does H3 News.
>> All these all these Pegasus and >> I have no issue
with people covering it. >> No. No. Do you not think
you should cover it? Why is this different to Tom for instance,
which you felt like you should cover? >> I honestly I I'm
not even against covering it. I think I if it's it's possible
that I might look at the thing is like
no that's totally reasonable but that because my whole argument
here is predicated on sort of like needling around and trying
to get you to to give statements that seem like you're unwilling
but if if you're like if if you're in a position where you're
like let's imagine let's imagine a world >> I think I would
I don't think I'd have a problem with doing a segment where I
look at what he has to say about the case and disagreeing with
it. So yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Well, that's fair enough. I think
that's totally fair. And that doesn't sound like, yeah, there's
any rush. It just seems like that's what you were saying is that
you weren't willing to give a statement. >> Well, the thing
is I'm not rushing to do it. It's not like I'm thinking like
I need to fire up a stream on this immediately, but like I have
no no issue with giving. >> That's fair. But let's say
let's say for instance, let's say I I make a Nick video. I'm
not going to make a Nick video just to be clear. This isn't like
me setting up. But let's say I make I feel like you have like
a >> really that really really kicks off like you know
gets a gets a decent amount of >> junk drawers video but
better and >> yeah junk draws video but like but like watchable
and like not [laughter] edited like three days and yeah >> let's
say someone makes that
would you be likely to cover it if it was like picking up steam
and people were interested and Alex Gway was tweeting about it
and there were spaces would you be like to cover that do you
think?
Um, I wouldn't be totally against covering it. I don't know if
I would rush to cover it though because it is about my friend
and I feel like that there is a certain level of disloyalty if
I'm like rushing to cover Oh, the new Nick video, you know? >> Sure.
But what what do you think would be like uh so what would determine
to you do you think? What would you look to to decide whether
you were going to cover it?
>> Um
what the video is saying, how much I enjoy the video. Uh, but
really just mainly like the
like effectiveness of like the points or whatever, right? Like
if it's just like a critique and like Nick's streams suck, that's
one thing. But if it's like a it's a pretty damning video on
stuff that Nick's like talked about, I don't know. I think I
think I would just base it off of like how much the video like
when I watch it personally
interests me in a way where I look at it and I'm just like, whoa,
you know, this needs to be talked about.
>> Okay. All right. >> Can I just ask real quick?
Are you waiting to see like if it's more
cuz he's your friend, but if it's more damaging to him, does
that push you away from covering it? Or if it's less like if
it's less damaging, are you more likely to cover it or if it's
more damaging, you more likely to cover it? Or is it maybe >> I
think I think he's saying more damaging, you'd be more likely
to cover it, right?
>> Yeah. If it was like a totally devastating video, if
it's like >> if it's just some
ag like, oh, Nick's fat, Nick's this or
or like or like, you know, he >> he lied about that girl
being his girlfriend or whatever in those photos years ago, whatever
the people or whatever, you know, that sort of [__]
>> I think fundamentally what this conversation comes down
to is I'm not afraid, and I was talking about this with Chud,
but I'm not afraid to admit that like with my friends or whatever,
right? I'm not rushing to expose them or to cover them
if I feel it's like unnecessary. I feel like there is like a
level of disloyalty that I feel by just >> I I agree with
you that jumping on like tiny little things at friends is like
you know what is even the point that you know like if you're
just blowing stuff up for the sake of >> the real answer
is this >> that is disloyal. The real, this is the real
thing, right? To truly be like an unbiased commentary, you really
can't have friends in this community. Like having friends is
where I up, right, in the first place, if we're really just being
honest, right? But I started this thing when I was really young.
I met Nick and Tom. We're good friends. I genuinely like them
as people and stuff like that, right? And as a result, that does
color my
willingness to sort of call them out or talk them because, you
know, I'm not trying to make my friends look bad.
And so, if people want to make the argument that you should never
have friends in the commentary community, like if you're a drama
YouTuber, you shouldn't be friends with other drama YouTubers.
I honestly kind of agree with that. But it's too late. You know,
I met these people. I like these people. I I just don't I don't
see the inherent, you know, like issue that where you can't,
you know, engage the same way as you do
>> with other people. >> It's like an attack on their
if they're up and you're just like adding on to the pile and
you're like, "Yeah, your whole stream is disingenuous. You run
a dog stream where you just lick Ethan Klein's balls and you
make all these like stupid lies and you just, you know, suck
his for clout and stuff like that, right? you're attacking his
brand, his business, and his credibility as a person.
And even if that's all true or not,
you doing that and adding on to that pylon as a friend, I see
as like
>> So, but you're saying like you can't It doesn't sound
like you're saying you can't have friends as a drama YouTuber.
You're saying you can't have friends who do immoral things and
can't take criticism about it. That's what you're saying. Because
I I I mean I you know I've had criticisms of Chad many times.
I've said you know I said Chud lost your debate. I said Chud
lost the debate at Pisco. You know I will sit there and criticize
Chad's takes I'll talk Chro
with Chud. Ch would talk about me. Ch makes jokes about you know
everyone in my committee being all this. It's like you know >> well
yeah I did the same though but it's I think it's like a it gets
into a different ball game when you're like fully attacking somebody's
like credibility. But we've done that too. We've got we've gone
at each other over King Daniel Green stuff. We've gone over at
each other over the um stop killing game stuff. There's a bunch
of dramas when me and Shard over it and it's just like car we
move on. We move on. >> Also, just just to be clear, it
it only gets there after you've like not talked for a long period
of time and a pattern of behavior builds up. You just talk to
somebody the first time it happens. They end up going like, "Hey,
don't you think this is weird?" They have a criticism. You go,
"Oh yeah, maybe that was weird." And then right like there's
a release valve if you could just criticize your friends openly.
Like that's to me what Chud's original criticism was when he
goes like uh Nicholas Yoro I'm talking to you. He talks about
suck it off like like Ethan Klein's doing or something. He says
Nicholas Yoro yes I am talking to you. It's like a little it's
a little nudge where it's like a release valve of like yeah that
is a criticism and feel free to hit me back on something.
>> But it seemed like Nick was like no actually I'm not
doing that. I'm not getting into that at all. M >> like
personally I think with friends you could do that even in this
space and it just doesn't seem like that big a deal. >> Maybe
I'm different. I just it really takes me a lot. It takes a lot.
I have to take a lot of before I fully decide all right you you
know even with Tommy C somebody I'm not even friends with but
like you know I really refuse to go in on him. Wait, that's the
thing. It doesn't have to be like a you. That's the thing. If
you don't if you say the first thing that happens and you're
like, "Hey, that's man." It's not a oh
>> But if if there are people who literally can't take
it when you start saying hey that's hey that's hey you've done
like three things. Plus everyone I know to be honest like if
>> everyone I know >> and I'm talking about real
life people along with internet people is most people I know
if I were to go up to them and be like hey you they would take
that extremely personally. Now I'm not the same way. If they
were to be like hey you I'd be like what's going on let's talk.
But most people that I know are not built like that. They just
can't take it. I don't I'm not around many people where I can
just be like, "Hey, you you're completely shit." And they could
just take
it.
>> Yeah. It's not going that hard. I think >> like
Do you think that's what you're saying when he says like, "Yeah,
Nicholas, I'm talking to you." When he like points at him and
he makes a he mocks him a little bit for consistently doing the
EHD stuff. Do you think that was a you? Oh, >> sorry. Uh
when Chad was saying that? >> Yeah. Yeah. When he did that
first call out or whatever, like do you think that was a you?
>> I'd interpret it that way.
>> But obviously I think Nick probably did.
>> Yeah. I think that's I think Nick saw it a different
way. Look,
I I do not take any I really try not to take anything seriously
at all. You know, like when people when Chub was calling me out
and said my streams are [__] I'm
>> Yeah. I mean, like genuinely though, like when Chub
was calling me out saying like, "Oh, my my RFC mania was like
you're some falling off streamer doing tricks for cash or whatever
the you >> tricks for treats." >> I didn't take that
super serious. I made fun of him back. You know what I mean?
But like I didn't take it super seriously. I think if you said
were to say the same thing about Nick, Nick would be like, "All
right, you're off." And I respect his perspective. I just look
at things differently. I don't really uh
I'm not really like I maybe I'm just not a combat and maybe that's
the problem. I'm in the drama industry but I'm not like a super
combative person. I really am not. I'm not looking for a fight
with anyone. I don't really am not looking for that energy. I
look for a fight with people that I already don't like and I'm
not friends with in the first place. But people that I am friends
with, I'm not looking for that kind of tension. So maybe I'm
just like a non-combative person and maybe that's like a problem
with doing drama content. I don't know. But I I don't see it
as a problem. But maybe that's just like the difference of >> No,
it's actually a huge It's actually a huge benefit. It makes you
way way more successful. But that it's it does lead to having
a bunch of dishonest friends
>> Well, possibly.
It's definitely possible.
But I'm really not looking for that kind of energy unless it
just is it's no there's no other option, you know, like Tommy
C went off on me today and I'm just like, "All right, there's
no other option. We're a lock and Tommy C for the end of the
year. Tommy Cy has to suffer." But it took a while for me to
get to that point, you know? So,
>> wait, you mean you're a Tommy C now? >> yes. Now,
you're now a Tommy C. >> Yes, but look at how long that
took, right? I mean, I thought you I thought you already kind
of had gone in on him to be honest. But >> no, I was always
kind of like, ah, he's cool. He's cool or whatever. Today, he
just was saying crazy. I'm just like at this point, it's like
[__] this guy. But it really takes me a long time
to get to that point. So, that's just like an >> But I
mean, let's think again again. I feel like it doesn't have to
ever like if you
Yeah. For a lot of I feel like it could just be
with Nick. Okay. Because we just we are constantly bringing back
to this. I'm trying to stop bringing back this but that's what
the conversation is about whatever for ages
>> with Nick it's like you point out one thing you point
out the second thing a third retired thing maybe doesn't have
a problem with that then the moment you ask question well Nick
you've done all of this Ethan Klein cogs in a row that seems
to be seems to be slight slightly off but not quite line up
um is this maybe being done for a reason you know you have that's
where the problem comes in that's where that's where it seems
got the problem comes in and you're willing to sit there and
say, "Oh, yeah, Nick may have this up or may have that up, but
what but you're not willing to take uh the the second step of
of drawing any conclusion that might reflect badly on him." And
it's like that that's where I see there's kind of like a problem
because I feel like if you were commentating, you know, over
anyone else, it it would be it would be a matter of okay, well,
I see you've done these stereotype things. This seems to be the
way you're acting and it seems that the reason why you don't
want to do that is because Nick Nick can't take it. Um, yeah,
that's a fair perspective. I can to I I can definitely see how
you think that. Um,
I just see it as like I'm not looking to cause a problem between
me and Nick. Nick's been nothing but good to me. So, I don't
really see any
motivation to sort of uh cause any problems for him. >> You're
you're not sweeping for yourself very You said your broom's very
powerful, but you're not sweeping for yourself very well. There's
like a you kind of >> I understand. It's just a losing
argument. There's nothing I can There's nothing I can say here
that wins. It's It's fine. But you just said like you just said
something that's worse than what you said before. I think you
said that you think this is just a business strategy. He's just
trying to make money any way he can. Embedded in that is that
like he's not going to be honest and you you're saying it. You
just don't want to go hard on Nick and say he's a lying he's
a lying fat and he deserves to like get cut off at the knees.
You're not going to say that. You don't have to go that far.
You're saying all the things you need to say to get like the
meaning >> This is a conversation where it's like >> I
personally think it's fine. This is a conversation where it's
like you either say something and I know Queen is going to say
well if you you know blah blah blah that means you really believe
it but look like all I can say is either Nick acts in a certain
way and I respect that or he's a giant who runs from conflict
and Queen would say that oh well that means that you think he's
a
>> but it's like dude >> yeah those aren't mutually
exclusive.
>> He's doing his thing. I'm not bothered by what he does.
>> No fair trying something else. string on something else.
So, now that Brandon Bucket was going around doxing, Salvo's
back in the house, right?
[laughter] >> Bring him in, dude.
>> Oh my god.
Brandon had shatter the Overton window there. [laughter]
>> What do you think about um two multi-millionaire male
YouTubers being roommates? What do we think about this? >> Two
male YouTubers being roommates. >> Yeah, two multi-millionaire
male YouTubers being roommates. They don't >> What was
that word you said before? >> Male. Male. Male. >> Okay.
Just male. >> It's not women living together. You
>> nothing wrong with that. What's wrong with that?
>> What? You think it's gay? You think they're like >> I
think it's just like a little bit strange. It doesn't randomly
have like a wife and kid.
yeah, I think so. Uh >> he's like roomies with like some
>> I don't know. YouTubers, dude. YouTube people have uh
content houses and [__] like that. It's >> they
don't make content together.
>> Yeah, but I'm sure they talk about it strategies. What
kind of question is >> Brian's out of work. >> You
think it's gay that they live together? Why? Maybe they're good.
Maybe they just get along with each other.
>> Maybe they just like living together. What's going on
there? Tom is hung like a Bulgarian like mind worker. Okay. And
Brandon's been out of for a while. We all know what's going on
there. >> That sounds >> No, wasn't gay at all. That
wasn't what I was implying. >> Maybe they just like spending
time together. I don't Is that gay? That sounds like a good male
bond. A good male. Sorry about being gay. >> I'm literally
not calling them gay. I literally said Tom is his bull. That's
I'm trying to make a I'm making it a [__] joke. Can
you pick it up, Auggie? >> Wow. Thank you.
Jesus Christ. >> Yeah, I'm not even saying they're gay.
I'm just saying like the idea that you know you're like he doesn't
make content, right? Brandon Buckham's totally out of commission
for the last six months. So they're not they're not doing cont
a content house. They're not really strategizing,
you know. It's just like a some 40-year-old dude with a wife
and kids like roomy. >> 40 years old. I don't think he's
that old. I think he's 20s. >> What is the health problems?
Is he on drugs or something?
>> I don't know anything about his drug >> Oh, sorry.
Like have you [laughter] >> I don't really know much about
Brandon to be honest at all. Like I just I've met him a couple
times. I I don't um I don't have I don't think he has like a
super favorable opinion of me. Um I like him though. >> By
the way, just say there's nothing wrong with it. Just say it's
like fine. They're friends. Who cares? >> They They are.
It's >> They probably like each other. They probably have
>> Don't let this Don't let this British twink push you
around. [laughter] >> I'm not I'm I'm pushing back.
>> All right, good. Was it even plugged in? That's [laughter]
a good question. >> It wasn't even plugged in. You know
there was there were no beeping sounds in the video that Brandon
technical. Did you know that?
>> Maybe it's for weird. >> Really now? Okay. This
is just getting into like levels of just [laughter]
>> this is just a this is beaming on um the guy Queenie
used to be friends with before he banned him from his Discord.
>> No, no. Augie Augie spoken to Perry. Oie's spoken to
Perry. >> Oh, Auggie knows who Perry is. Okay. All right.
I didn't know that. Cool, cool, cool, cool, cool.
Oh, true. Augie was roommates with X8. That is they couldn't
possibly be gay to live with another
>> True. I live with Got >> There's a There's a bias
here. I'm speaking to a
>> live be honest on this topic.
>> Didn't think about that. >> It's not the same
though if you're both like in your 20s. It really isn't the
>> You think there's a difference between a guy in his
20s living with somebody in their 30s or whatever? >> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. There's a difference.
>> I can see like 20s and like 40s. That's like crazy.
No, there's nothing crazy about that. You guys are insane. >> Brandon
Buckingham age. It's having a wife and kids. It's more than age
having a wife and kids.
>> Having a wife. >> Yeah. Okay. It was having a
wife and kids and living with like some kid. >> Yeah. Tom's
like the older brother. What's wrong [laughter] with that? >> Well,
like I even wonder like he they live there with him. Is that
like what how it is or >> I don't know his living arrangement,
>> That's like bizarre. That's like so >> Is that
like a hang up? Do people in England do do British people not
room together? I mean, it's like a >> Yeah, but like not
when you've got like a like you're rooming with like a white.
>> Also, when you've got no resources, that's why you room
together. Yeah, but there's no restraint on these two. There's
no restraint. That might be the only way to see that guy. Okay.
You might that might be the only way you get to see that guy
if he's married. He's got to have >> If I'm married, if
I'm married and I live with my best friend, that's like the best
arrangement I could possibly imagine. I'm not confined to my
stupid wife and my whiny ass baby kid. I have my friend around
me and stuff like that. That's a good arrangement. That's a solid
arrangement. I like that.
>> Tom can give fashion advice to your kids. Sorry.
>> Oh, that's a that's a joke about age playing. Oh, I
get I get the joke. I
>> I mean, he definitely likes that stuff. I I don't need
Augie's comment on it. It's fine.
He definitely likes that stuff. I just personally am of the opinion
that, you
the age play or the kids, Jason, you have to clarify otherwise.
>> The age play obviously. >> Okay. Okay. >> I'm
not totally down with people being obviously don't think Turkey's
>> Okay. Okay.
>> I'm just saying if he likes uh
you think he's definitely doing age play. What? Because he met
met up with the girl.
>> Um met up with the girl. I think there's like a little
some little interesting >> Oh, wait. No, this will be good.
This will be good. Okay. Do you think Kai is lying? Do you think
Kai is lying in her statement that she says she's not into any
age play? >> I don't know her enough to say if she's I
I take her word as true. I don't know her personally. I don't
>> you you don't have like some other take on it. You don't
feel like you >> I mean I just think it's true. Why Why
do you think she's lying? Let's hear. Well, because Aiden,
so the the story is, and this basically confirmed, is that basically
Lis was gossiping to Aiden and says years ago when she goes back
with Tom or whatever, oh yeah, she she pre
or whatever.
>> And um Aiden takes this and leaks this. And when Aiden
leaks it, Lar reaches out and says, "Hey man, I was just gossiping
and making you know, I was just making up all the time back then.
you know, like like the stuff I told Jaylen, but like all the
stuff he told Jaylen was like basically true. I think Salvo
made up the idea that he carved her name, but the I believe that
as far as we can tell, he did pro he seem to self harm, you know,
um did there was cheating, you know, all this stuff did seem
basically happened, he said Jaylen. So, as far as we can tell,
everything else he leaked or gossiped about was true. Uh but
apparently now this one is the one that's false. And it just
so happens that it totally benefits
uh Liam, who has a history of allegations, lollycon allegations
against him. It benefits Kai, who's planning to start a streaming
career soon? >> I think that Liam is the one that was doing
the age play. All right. >> Do you think Liam was the one
doing the age play? Which way round? Him pretending to be a child
or Kai pretending to be a child? >> Well, I don't know.
I definitely think he was involved in some sort. I think they
do both. >> Both. Both. Yeah. I think Liam was the one
that was doing it. Um, if I were to throw like a speculation
like that. But, um, I did hear your take. You were basically
saying like because so Kai's trying to start her own streaming
career
>> I don't think she wants to follow in. I don't think
she >> obviously she doesn't want like a nuclear war with
Tom to interrupt that. >> Not just that, but just she doesn't
want to be known as an age player, you know, like you wouldn't
you would go into streaming being known as >> I mean that's
definitely a possible motivation there.
Um,
is she lying though? I mean, I I take Tom at his word. He says
he hasn't done that. Kai says they didn't do that. Uh, the weird
Ellie girl said they don't do that. So, prove it. That's what
I say. >> Yeah. I can't prove it obviously. I just I don't
believe her. I think that's a lie. I think that's too convenient.
And Lar said it at a time where I don't think he would have just
>> lied about that cuz the other stuff wasn't nice. Would
you go fly out to hang out with a girl who was wearing the stuff
that that girl was wearing or >> no? No. No. No. That person
was >> No, cuz that obviously that person's into some weird
sick [__] I mean, I don't think that that necessarily
means that Tom was engaging in that with her. I think he probably
just saw some girl that was like he thought was hot on Instagram,
was like, "Let's" But a person like that is like, "No, you got
nothing. That that's not a the good type of person you want to
be hanging around. That is no no go. >> What do you What
do you think you thought was hot about it? I'm sorry. Uh >> probably
that she was an adult woman that's into the e-girl aesthetic
and he probably liked that. I don't know. >> Yeah. Okay.
I'm not going to press any >> I mean, not every picture,
just to be clear, I've seen like the sketchy pictures of her.
Not every picture of her she looks like that.
Just to be clear. So she very obvious of her. Do you think if
somebody off their
>> No.
No.
They met her in real life. No. I feel like if they were like
cruising Instagram and they saw pictures of Bel Deline looking
like a little kid and they slid in the DMs based on that and
tried to [__] her then I would be like
>> I mean Belie's like obviously an adult
>> Uh yeah.
Yeah. I'm saying >> every picture I've seen of Beline online,
like on Twitter, she looks like >> But like how old is
Bel Deline? Like how long has she been doing this for? Like a
>> I would say when she was younger, she did look young.
She looked like way
>> I don't know. I'm just thinking about her like when
she was doing content like Touad and stuff like that, when I'd
see pictures of her, she looked like a grown woman. And if somebody
was attracted to that person, I'd be like, "Oh, you're attracted
to grown women."
>> Okay.
Show the skirt picture. I'm not going to show the skirt picture
right I mean, you're obviously attracted to like some weird egirl
BBD hoe, but like you're still attracted to a grown woman at
the end of the day, right? >> Does she look like a old?
>> Yeah. Well, hold on. I don't think I don't think that
makes you a >> But I think you see something there that
you want to go hang out with
>> that is weird. I agree with that. I I think that that's
definitely >> but but also I don't I just as long as he's
not like for me the way I look at this is if you have the self-control
to not talk about this and you just kind of like like some aesthetics
around this and you're only talking to adults then I'm totally
fine with all of that. Right. I don't have a problem with all
of that. So I have no problem saying I suspect that he's like
kind of into that stuff. I think there's >> I don't give
a [__] about it either way. My my issue is literally
the the way he presents online is is just like >> Oh, it's
hypocritical, too. Yeah. Yeah. >> It's just it's the it's
the gay as he does this gay puritan attitude. You do it to a
little bit orgy as well. I'm not going to lie. Um the like commentary
Kend Doll where you just sit there act like oh so crazy that
anyone could be could be I mean to be honest you're both doing
it right now being like oh how could anyone be interested in
this girl? She's wearing kid clothes in this one [__]
in this one picture. It's like, well, because she looks like
a [__] only fan's going off for pictures. That's
That's why. >> Well, that's what I'm saying. I've I've
never Wait, Augie said that. I've never seen those pictures.
I've only seen the uh the youngl looking ones.
>> Um, okay. Wait, Queen, did you just accuse me of having
that same position or do you think I was hinting at that same
position? I said right away. >> I see you. You were doing
I said you were doing that thing with regards to that that girl.
>> I wouldn't [__] somebody that looks like
a child. I Yeah, I was saying that like there's a reason he wanted
to meet up with that girl, right? And I'm I'm saying that I don't
think that that's like necessarily sick because it's with an
adult, right? That he confirmed as an adult before he went to
find her or went to see her. I don't think there's like necessarily
necessarily something sick there. I just don't think you should
talk about like your fetishes and stuff broadly on streams. I
think it's like >> mostly
especially show.
Well, I think I don't think you should because it's like embarrassing,
but do you think there's something wrong with doing it? >> Unless
you're Mr. Girl, you can get away with it. >> I especially
if they're society wrong, it is like a lack of self-control that
you feel like you need to talk about it that I think is concerning.
It's like for example, the the food shops like um stuff where
she felt like she had to talk about it.
I think that lack of self-control is very uh >> yeah, I
want to pass out the difference between there being like an action
that's wrong versus an action that's sort of like transgressive
and maybe could reflect on the person a certain way but isn't
100% cuz it sounds like you're saying this is something it's
like a red flag to me like I I look at someone with a side eye
if they're doing this but are you saying it's wrong to
>> Um how do I put it? I'm not sure it's wrong to do. I
don't feel like I'm saying it's wrong to do. I'm saying it's
like um like I'm concerned about that person being like having
some uh like a lack of self-control.
>> I'm like less committed. I do think there's probably
something to be said for like um like normalizing certain things.
There's conversations about normalizing certain things that I
think could be weird, but I it's probably where people who have
thought about it. I don't mind people doing um like thoughtout
pieces on stuff like that if they've got like some argument they're
making. they're presenting something novel, but if they're just
like, I don't really care about this. They're having like a conversation
about it. I think it's it's weird. It comes off as to me as weird.
I don't know if I go so far as to say it's morally wrong.
>> But yeah, like um I don't know. Like food shop's just
a perfect example of like there was literally no benefit to you
doing this and you had to talk about it. That makes me very concerned.
And then obviously the lies that went along with it as well.
There major red flags going on there.
>> Yeah. I I think to be honest I don't really put that
much on talking about the lies are the bigger issue. I I guess,
you know,
I do look at, you know, I'm the I'm the same where it's like,
you know, someone says they're into I'm obviously look at them
with a side eye, but I don't see anything. I'm not I don't think
it's a wrong act to admit to being into, you know, it just makes
you seem like there's a increased chance you're a repetitive.
>> Yeah. I think what I'm doing there is adding the weight
of like how socially
I don't know how much of a social outcast you look like when
you do that and that somebody willing to do that like um somebody
who's willing to do that. I think yeah probably poorly socially
conditioned. >> I think it depends how much
>> of really I think it depends on how much looks maxing.
I think it depends on how much you're looks maxing. >> I
mean, that's like the real answer for like basically everything
pretty much. It's like >> this is why Epstein was not
>> like some guys can just get away with it. Like I was
having a conversation with somebody about like Flamco and they
were like, "Didn't Flamco his argument about why he looked at
is because he imagined himself as like the little boy
>> Yeah, exactly. And I'm like, yeah, the reason why that
argument doesn't work is because he looks like the if he was
like a looks maxed like guy, he could probably maybe have gotten
away with that, but because he looks like a disgusting got in
this same turkey drama, he would have gotten away with it. Nobody
would have even batted an
>> Well, the girl wouldn't have even reported him, right?
>> Yeah, I think
if it was Hassan.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I believe that.
I'm pretty sure I can't remember what the stat is, but there's
like some crazy stat about like there being a huge crossover
between like auto
so
when you see yourself as a kid so so like when people say like
I've heard trans people say that [__] as well where
they're like oh I was looking at the because I myself as a kid
it's like it doesn't actually make it any better like statistically
I'm pretty sure it's like actually you're just as like
>> that's one of the leading theories for how develops
right you get somehow Like that's why there's such a high correlation
with sexual as a child. >> Yeah. A lot of the time >> is
you you crystallize like your development as you with you as
a child
yeah like it halts there. You get like arrested development of
your
>> I don't know. I think we should ask Destiny what he
thinks about this. He's in the chat, right?
[laughter] >> I don't think so. Uh I don't think
>> He is on vacation though. That is when he tends to come
in when he has to hang around other human beings, catch a
>> So, you never know.
>> Is he somewhere with not soite? If if he was somewhere
with not a erodite, he would definitely be in the chat tonight.
You know, you know it for a fact.
>> Who wouldn't?
>> You got to escaping her. >> Yeah, I'm I'm probably
going to bounce out of here, but uh >> All right. >> Good
talk. Good talk, guys.
>> Yeah, we'll chat later.
See you.